Did Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com but if
you've heard the podcast before,
you already know that.
So I'll spare you most of the nonsense.
If you use the code name Rogan,
you get 10% off any and all supplements.
The supplements are the
best shit available.
The Best Shit we can find.
We sell you the stuff
that we actually use.
I've been a fan of nootropics long before
I ever got involved in being a a pitch
man.
But uh,
I am a firm believer in healthy diet and
nutrients for your body and I believe
that nootropics are beneficial
for cognitive function.
I take them,
um,
and that's why we sell them.
Alpha brain is the best
combination of nootropics.
We know how to put together if
there was a better combination,
if there's a better way to do it,
we would do that way.
That's just what we do.
The,
the whole idea.
But that sounded so douchey.
That's just what we do.
I sound like a girl who's
like talking about her team.
We win.
That's just what we do.
I apologize for that.
Look,
I had loved these fucking things and
sometimes I don't even know what I'm
saying.
It comes out of my mouth.
I'm like,
really dude.
Yeah,
really dude,
if I had a chance to edit this,
it'd be way better,
but I don't.
Uh,
all the other shit that we sell,
whether it's hemp force,
we were selling you the best quality
hemp protein that is available,
it is sweetened with natural
sweeteners is called Stevia.
There's like one gram
of sugar in a serving.
It's completely negligible.
And the,
the,
the beneficial nutrients that
you get from it are fantastic.
It's got raw cocoa in it,
which is a,
an excellent antioxidant.
It also has Maka in it,
which is a testosterone booster,
very healthy root.
So the,
the,
the hemp protein powder that
we sell is the highest quality,
highest protein content available.
So it's all substantial nutrition
and it tastes fucking great.
And we got kettle bells and battle ropes
and go get yourself some grass fed beef
son,
gay shit together.
All right,
get your shit together.
Use the code name Brogan,
save 10% off any and all supplements.
We are also brought to you by death squad.
Dot.
TV desk squad.
Dot TV is where the year.
So those shirts that everybody who,
where do you get these death squad
shirts people wear at our shows?
Those are all available at desk squad.
Dot TV.
And they are the creation
of Brian Red band.
They are 100% his.
He doesn't,
it's like,
isn't it?
You're not just buying a shirt from
a guy who like commissioned artists.
Like if you,
if you buy any of my
higher primates shirts,
I pay a dude to draw those things.
Like Brian actually makes these cats,
you know,
love him or hate him.
They're,
they're trippy as fuck.
And the new one,
uh,
that the new cat is my
favorite cat for sure.
We've got to do something with that dude.
Oh wait.
Do you see the newer,
newer one that I'm working on right now?
Um,
I'm nervous because this
was so fucking nervous.
Do you think I'm nervous?
It's hard to fucking do this now.
I'm like,
I got to make it better than the last one.
They're so weird.
You know the,
the strapped up with dynamite
and fuck crazy looks at it.
So it's like,
what is the message here?
Like what the fuck is the message here?
He has probably that we,
I have a great park,
has a Tom Green is Steevo
at death squad ITV TV.
Right now we just put
as Kat von D and dead.
Oh,
that's okay.
This is the ones that you've
been doing on Mondays.
Yeah.
Lots of great podcasts at a desk.
One on iTunes.
We got Kevin Pereira if you've
ever seen attack of the show.
Kevin prayer was a host for the longest
time and now he has one of the best
podcasts on the Internet.
Yeah,
it's fucking awesome.
The dude is just,
he's so smart and he's so cool and he's
just so in the right groove all the
time.
I love talking to that guy and I love
his podcast and it's called pointless and
you can catch that on
iTunes and it's all always,
all this shit is free.
Always free.
It will keep it free.
Except my comedy special bitch.
You got to pay for that.
It's only five bucks though,
you know,
when Louis C K set out to do it.
I think if you have to look at like,
uh,
the best comics in the country right now,
I'd say Louis C K is like right
at the very top of the heap.
So when Louis C K puts
a comedy special out,
it's five bucks.
You can't make your six,
you know,
you got to do five bucks too stupid,
or four.
Well,
how about you be a little humble.
You're shit's worth about three 50,
you know?
But,
um,
the,
uh,
the ability to do that,
that Louie exposed was a huge,
I mean,
it was just an amazing new thing.
Like a light went off in
my head when I saw it,
I was like,
oh my God,
that's how I'm doing
everything from now on.
It's just like,
I wish I'd thought of it myself,
but I'm so glad he did.
And um,
it's available DRM free on Joe rogan.net.
It's only five bucks.
You can get it,
you can use paypal.
And Amazon and uh,
I paid for the whole thing.
I paid to get it produced
and filmed and edited.
Any costs of gifted.
Like I sent one to my dad.
He just guided,
I just got an IPAD and apple TV.
So now he's all appling it out.
So I send them a,
I said it goes to his email.
He just clicks on it and downloads
it and then he could just,
you know,
streaming right.
Two is a TV.
That's great.
I always had that uncomfortable moment
when I have to talk to dude after he seen
my act for the first time.
Especially
the older guy.
He's already seen you.
Oh really?
Maybe you saw you like seven years ago
when we were there for the men of men of
color.
Oh,
the,
yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
Yeah,
we did.
That's right.
Yeah.
All right.
We'll start this podcast ladies.
Gentlemen.
Andrew dice clay is here.
Bitches respect,
experience.
[inaudible]
New Year's Eve.
You dirty fucks.
It's going down and drew mother
fucking dice clay where it will be.
How the,
how can I say it?
Showtime.
Showtime,
10:00 PM on showtime.
On showtime.
Is this something you've worked,
you've already filmed,
it's not going to be,
no,
I've shown this already.
You said you were very happy with it,
really happy with it.
But you know,
I really stayed on it from beginning 10.
I had a concept,
you know,
that I wanted to do as far as I'm
concerned the most like an ultimate
rock and roll standup show
to really bring excitement,
you know,
because like,
you're very animated on stage,
you know,
you're all over the place,
you move,
you know,
you could see that life and you,
and that's like the one thing that
always bothered me about Comedians,
that they don't know too
much about performance art.
Especially,
you know,
when the cameras are rolling,
everybody thinks that great and then the
cameras turn on and they stand like a
fucking mummy,
you know?
So I really wanted to give a real
edgy rock and roll's special.
And you know,
as you've met before,
my son's,
you know,
La Rocs opens the show.
Um,
Eleanor Kerrigan,
you know,
who opens my,
my shows is in the special,
which you never even see an
opening act in a one hour special.
And it's just from the second
it starts to the second it ends.
It's just exciting and it's fucking funny,
you know?
And that's,
that's what I wanted to deliver.
I wanted to give people something that,
you know,
especially,
the way the world is today,
the whole political
correctness fucking shit.
You know?
And I wanted,
I made sure there was nothing
politically correct about this factual,
you know,
because you know what comics are
being put on trial in telling,
you know,
a gay joke or a black joke and you know,
now,
now the whole world,
what do you think,
you know,
when,
when Tmz stop and you go,
what do you think of,
you know,
Tosh,
Daniel tosh saying this,
I go,
it's a fucking joke.
Isn't that the point?
Are we allowed to comment
on what goes on socially,
you know,
in the world.
And since when is someone joking and
being serious at the same time since when
is that a real statement?
When someone's saying something
that's obviously ridiculous,
they don't really mean that.
You're so stupid,
you can't interpret that.
You can't,
you know,
why are we,
why are we running for office medians?
And the idea is that when,
when someone says something offensive,
that's a joke.
The idea is that somehow it's the exact
same thing as saying something offensive
about a person,
whether it's a racist thing or
a gay thing for being crude,
having an argument and
calling somebody a name.
No,
we're not saying it for an effect.
That's right.
And it's an art form and people,
you know,
this is,
a time where people need to really laugh.
You know,
I,
I really want that,
the New Year's Eve spot
because you also know,
you know,
especially cause that hurricane
happened on these coasts.
And I know a lot of people don't go out,
it's house parties and I just want this
stomachs to fucking hurt from the things
I'm saying on that stage.
Well listen,
I saw you in Vegas,
me and Norton and funny and Oh yeah,
yeah.
Red Band came Sam,
uh,
from a opiate Anthony show and we had
the fucking best time cause that's like,
it's a rare treat for me to be able to
go and just sit down and be
an audience member and enjoy.
Yes.
At a great show and seeing
somebody that won't aw,
no matter where.
You know,
the first time I even did Vegas years ago,
uh,
for,
you know,
for the comedy store when the
comedy store was at the dunes,
I got fired the second night,
you know,
full language,
and you know,
is this you?
Is this the new special yeah.
It,
yeah.
I want,
you know,
I didn't,
I didn't wear anything too
intense as far as an outfit.
I didn't want to go with the LVC jackets.
You know,
I went through it very street.
I want to stage to look street,
you know,
is show you put on in
Vegas was fucking awesome.
I really enjoyed it for this,
you know,
prepared for it in Vegas
and around the country.
But I did,
you know,
just pissed you had 28 weeks in Vegas.
You know,
I just wanted a tight,
because as good as you think it might
be when the cameras are rolling,
like I said,
you all going to fuck up a little,
you know,
like I was doing this one bit where I
left out a whole chunk of the bit because
I was so into like performing for the
crowd that after the show was over,
you know,
the producers were like,
my wife funes she goes,
you left out this,
this and this.
You know.
But that was the warmup,
you know?
And then the second show I came out to
just annihilate the crowd and the crowd
was,
you know,
it was bedlam.
It was as insane as I was,
you know,
was,
it was very reminiscent of my first
special as far as the audience reaction.
The energy.
Yeah.
We did it in Chicago.
I mean the band kicked ass.
I mean,
do you feel like you're
having like a resurgence?
It's,
it's a complete resurgence,
you know?
I mean,
just by the response of the people,
you know,
years ago,
when I would say certain
things with women,
you know,
it was the Ah,
that she say,
you know,
and today when I,
when I,
you know,
when I tell them what piglets
they've become duty years now,
they got that fist pumping in the air.
Like yeah,
dice,
you know,
for an error.
Right.
People are more accepting
of fucked up shit now.
But also people have changed because
a lot of what I talk about his sexual,
you know,
and women have changed.
They're the ones that wrote the material,
you know,
that,
in this day and age,
you know,
I had a call from a friend
of mine that was with a girl,
went out with a thought,
she was a sweet girl and you know,
they wound up just doing everything
imaginable to each other.
And he tells me,
so I call it the next day,
you know,
to see how she's doing,
letting her know,
like it's not forgotten.
Like I want to see you.
And she goes,
I'll call you right back.
And she never even called me again.
He said,
he goes,
I was the one night stand.
But that's how things have changed,
that they've become so aggressive.
You know,
you can't go by the face,
you can't go by.
Oh,
she's got that girl next door look,
you know,
and the next thing you know,
she's a contortionist view,
you know,
wrapping her feet around the back
of her neck while you're banger.
You know what I mean?
That's what it is today.
That didn't exist before.
Well,
you know why I didn't have one like that.
You know,
I haven't hit the contortionists thing,
but you know,
I always thought a woman
in the bedroom or you know,
in a subway,
wherever you might be
banging her at the time,
you know,
a dressing room,
whatever a but car,
whatever.
You know,
when Allie,
you know,
should be the kind of woman she wants
to be like that she doesn't have to hold
back.
Because I always felt like
a lot of relationships,
you know,
like I'm married now for the third time
and I feel a lot of relationships start,
you know,
splitting apart because people are an
honest at the beginning about what they
like,
how they like to be.
You know,
years ago a woman wouldn't let you know
all these little things that might,
you know,
push her buttons and sooner or later
she's doing it with some other guy because
she's now afraid to tell
you what she's about.
And you know,
I would always let a woman,
no,
just be the pig that you are.
If I had to say comedically,
you know what I mean?
Be what you want to be.
I don't judge that way.
Yeah.
I think slowly but surely everyone's
going to just be what they want to be
because of it.
Yeah.
But,
but when you,
when you were in a relationship
and you don't start out that way,
you know,
that's where the problems could,
could arise.
Awesome.
People grow in different directions,
you know,
that happens to one person would get
freaky or the other person wants to settle
down more.
Well,
you know what,
you know,
I,
I always said,
what guy that's with a woman for
a bunch of years in the audience?
I go,
what are you going to leave her?
Just the fallen hate all over again.
You know?
Cause it always starts out nice.
You know what I mean?
And then a couple of years later,
it's that fucking money grubbing
a hole all the way to plaintiff.
Yeah.
How was,
you know,
so is it possible to break that chain?
How do you break that chain?
You know,
we're doing good,
you know,
me and my wife doing good.
She seems happy.
She's always smiling.
You're always smiling when you weather.
Yeah.
She makes me happy.
We make each other happy.
Is it just a matter of
getting the right combination,
the right to humans?
You know what it is.
You really do have to search that out.
And you know,
I'm not going to sit here and make like,
we'd never had an argument.
I mean,
she's Latin,
you know?
I mean,
it gets crazy sometimes,
but we always know that with tight,
that's what keeps you together.
I mean,
an argument happens with anybody,
but you got to know that,
you know,
you got all these other things in the
relationship that keep you together.
Right?
Yeah,
yeah.
If you'd just,
but that's,
you know,
but that's what I taught.
You know,
when I,
when I'm on stage,
it's a different side of me.
It's,
you know,
it's,
an animal unleashed that
when I'm on a stage,
I could just have the freedom to say
things the way I see it and paint these
crazy,
almost like pornographic
comedic cartoons for people.
And they laugh because
they know that doing it,
you know what I mean?
They know,
you know,
when you see a couple and you,
you do,
you know,
with similar in that thing,
you say what you feel onstage and whenever
you see those couples that look at
each other and laugh,
those are the couples that go,
how does he know?
How does he know what an animal I am?
You know what I mean?
How does he know this?
You know?
But that's research.
You know,
you go through life and
you learn different things.
Research.
Yeah.
It's gotta be research.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Everything is research really.
I was with a contortionist recently
and I thought it would be amazing.
I mean,
I always picture it would be amazing,
but she's always just really sore and
she always has a fucked up Chin because
there were Chin's always
on the floor and shit.
Like,
really?
Yeah.
And I'm a Chin Guy.
Like you have to have s I don't like
wait Chan's where it's just like,
Whoa,
whoa.
You know?
And then when it's,
when it's a nice Tampa,
it's all like scratched up and rashy
they use the bottom of the channel.
They're always on their chins.
Yeah.
That's interesting to me.
I,
you know,
I haven't hit that yet.
Wow.
We do any chin work.
There's no chin work and us.
What do you mean with the chin?
Because like when they do contortionist
don't lie to me,
our photo,
it's a good mobile
coming into the new year,
just fucking around with me.
I'm going to get 900% like a lot of times.
Well at Brown poodle photo for him.
Photo up at the Chins Chin.
Okay.
How would you even have that here?
She worked.
I have been,
and I say where she works,
but she,
she uh,
she would always be in a position where
her face is always on the ground in a
wet feet.
Go all the way over the
black brown hair like this,
you know,
so she's like sitting there like that.
Just her,
her,
whenever she's doing contortion is,
she's always on her chin here.
I started some photos.
If you look at a TV right there,
like,
uh,
absolutely the snow you don't see
like see like this right here,
like this kind of stuff where
she has her chin right here,
girl that,
you know,
this is not her to seven,
but
uh,
no,
he's just going seven year old woman.
This is a woman,
a woman.
See that,
that woman's legs,
she's doing
chins on the ground.
You'd never think about it.
Pick a torsion is always happy.
Patients are younger.
If you're stepping on a
head and you're in there,
you know what I mean?
That's no good.
So that just a weird
position to put your body.
Yeah,
that's not a position I could get
into one thing and then in sexy,
just don't think about it like,
yeah,
you look at their legs,
bend really far back when you were
putting them up above your legs,
but you're not going like,
all right now,
can you been in this backwards?
I just wouldn't make it a meatball or
to stretch what you check before you
begin.
No,
I don't.
It's easily,
it's probably better than a
chick with a hamstring pull up.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
If it was the opposite,
like owl,
don't pull my leg out.
Be better off of the contortions.
That's funny to me.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
See he looks like a nice guy,
right?
He looks like no,
but I'm saying it looks
like a regular nice guy,
but look what he's into.
Well,
you just gave it a shot.
In his defense,
he didn't necessarily say he was into it.
You've got a girlfriend right now.
Sure.
Yeah.
No,
nothing steady.
Yeah,
I have.
Yeah.
I have a steady in a,
yeah,
to what does that even mean?
It means he's retarded.
If you didn't know what you just went,
this is called a web.
A Web.
You got caught in a spiderweb,
the spiderweb of retardation.
It sticks to you and you're like,
oh my God,
I'm in this conversation
and I can't get out.
What the fuck did I do?
What did I engage him?
And you're trying to pull
yourself out of struggle,
but now you know we're into something.
What's going on?
I don't know why you're invested in this,
you know?
But what happened?
I'm just dating.
That's I guess the easiest way to say it.
I should say dating.
He's trying to,
you know,
I like you.
You know I'm not starving down.
You know I'm dating now.
That's what a girl says,
that she broke up with
a guy up to six months.
Well,
I'm starting to date.
You see what I mean?
Yeah,
I know.
Yeah.
I'm just trying not to jump
right into a relationship.
Very cool podcast here.
You can't use expressions like that.
Yeah,
you can't do,
you know,
and I like you,
we're friends.
What am I supposed to say?
You know,
I'm banging a few of them out,
right.
The show.
You know what I mean?
You know,
I throw a load this way.
I splurged all over this one before
I came to work just for a golf.
You know what I mean?
Things like that.
It needed the show.
You gotta realize you never got
to go back to this a podcast.
That's the beauty of that.
She can say what you want.
You never going to go back
to being an accountant again.
This will never haunt you.
It was he an accountant.
He used to sell computers.
Europe,
he's a good guy.
Very good guy.
But you know,
he's got to hit a mouthful.
It's a mass.
Well,
you're with them a lot,
but a mess and no doubt
that he's a great guy.
I'm just messing a good way.
Like what is,
what's going on?
I mean,
at one side of his mouth I'm pink,
socking Asians,
making them pee a little.
But what I'm saying is
deciding your mouth.
You're talking about dating and on
the other side you're showing girls,
you know,
twisting themselves into pretzels.
But that wasn't really
like a sexual thing.
No,
no,
but it can be.
Yes,
because what he said,
that's what he saying.
Brian,
you just retarded yourself out.
Now you're cutting your own web,
your own weapons wrapped you right.
We'll leave him alone.
He's got it.
He's in his defense.
He's a very unusual dating situation.
It seems to be working out and he doesn't
want to talk about him in the air.
Right.
So what do you want to talk about
that we were talking about you.
We are,
we are,
um,
I try not to be so like crazy with myself.
I really tried to stay like grounded
in what I do because it does feel a little
crazy right now with what's going on.
Like you said about a resurgence and well,
you seem real excited
about comedy again to like,
you know,
you know what it is.
I've watched a lot of the specials and
when I spoke to showtime about this,
you know,
I had a couple of rules because I
even told my director a Scotsman Toya,
I said,
look,
you know you're going to
go through something now.
This isn't going to be like
the other specials you've done.
You're going to,
you know,
your head is going to change
color because of this.
You know,
you're going to go through it with me now.
You're going to be a different
man when you come through this.
And what was funny is
he,
when we were going to do the special,
he spoke to Joe does,
you know,
and he goes,
he taught me,
you know,
it goes to d as it goes,
I'm thinking of doing a special with dice,
what do you think?
And he goes,
well I think he's great but
you're going to go through it.
You know,
you know he's crazy when
it comes to these things.
And I am,
because all the way from the
performance to the editing,
I want it to be perfect.
I want people like,
like in a capsule because I really
don't want to do any more specials.
Like I'm going to do the road
now I'm just finishing up,
you know,
deal with the hard rock in Vegas,
a long term deal.
And you know,
I want to do what I do on the road.
Now.
What are you going to do at the hardrock?
Same thing you would do at the river.
Yeah.
Doing Monkey.
Uh,
yeah,
I'm going to do like two
weeks at a clip and go into a,
uh,
what's the name?
Vinyl.
It's a rock club,
you know,
and like I said,
I base my act on rock and roll,
so I like a certain setting,
you know,
it's not that big of a room,
it's just there.
I was just in Vegas,
uh,
two weeks ago.
It's great.
The new hard rock is grain.
Well,
you know,
with what I do in that hotel,
it really fits.
And you know,
Vegas is somewhere I like to be a lot.
So,
you know,
on the road,
you know what it is,
you go into a couple thousand seats,
it's one time a year.
But Vegas,
I like doing like 20 weeks,
24 weeks a year.
And you know,
me and my wife just go nuts there.
We have a great time.
And you know,
it's like a home away from home.
Why did you choose Vegas
to work out your shows?
Why'd you decide to do it
that way and not do it in la?
Well,
I was,
I was doing clubs around the country,
you know,
so I did that.
I did the,
you know,
like the governor's,
all those clubs,
you know,
but,
but Vegas was like a steady thing.
It was,
it almost became like my comedy store.
So,
you know,
I was at the Las Vegas Hilton
for a while working on it.
And then we went the Riv before the
Hilton and then we went back to the river
because I,
I was never into the room
at the Hilton to start with.
But you know,
you have,
you know,
I have a,
invest is in the show and you know,
we tried it,
but the river was a great room
to really just work it out,
do as long as set as I want,
and really just make everything
tight and develop the material with,
with an audience that's coming to see me.
So when you have the people
that are paying to come see you,
you know,
if the material is good,
because that's the fans.
Now when you go on places
like the comedy store,
you're going to get those
people that you know,
look at you and go,
what did he just say?
I want to leave now.
You know,
and I didn't want to deal with that.
I want the real audiences.
I thought that was a brilliant
idea to do it at the Riv,
uh,
for,
for that reason that you would
get all your people there,
but also because the place
has so much fucking history.
Oh yeah.
Such a crazy hotel.
I get people that perform this,
the,
you know,
from Sinatra,
Sammy Davis to,
uh,
you know,
comics like Milton Berle and you know,
Jack Benny,
who personally,
I wasn't ever even fucking
in tow because like I say,
I wasn't,
I was never that much into standups.
But you know,
when you're on a stage that,
you know,
Sinatra was on,
I did a lot of rooms like that in Vegas.
I did 'em before they knocked it.
Uh,
what was the stardust?
I did the status for a few years.
Wow.
And that was one of the best
stages because that stage,
you know,
you had the stage that you,
you're on like this and then it had a,
what's it called?
Like a runway that went right
through the entire audience.
And they don't build
stages like that anymore.
So I was lucky enough to play some of
those Bally's hotel I did for 13 years.
Isn't it crazy with those old Vegas
hotels that when they're done with them,
they explode them?
It's crazy because you know,
I think,
you know,
pee,
I know a lot what goes on in Vegas and
like these people that just bought the
Sahara want to make it like
more of a boutique hotel.
Again,
you know,
for high role is not a lot of kids,
not a thousand floors up.
You know,
it was smaller place where people
really feel that old school Vegas feel.
Right.
And I also think they,
this is really becoming
a place for comedy,
not just comedy.
Falive entertainment because of recession.
You know,
when people come to Vegas,
if they're going to go to a show,
they want to see somebody
familiar to them.
Right.
You know,
so that's why a lot of
comics are moving there,
you know?
And that's why a lot of,
you know,
you see people like share performing
that just sort of guns and roses there.
You know,
it's that type of place.
Now they want to see
people that are fans of,
they don't want to see just,
you know,
a bunch of midgets on Bungee cord
jumping around to the Beatles music.
You know,
you could probably do like a weekly
show in Vegas and never have to travel
anywhere and just made people traveling.
I want it to you.
I want it to her,
you know,
I owe it to myself.
I owe it to,
to the fans that,
you know,
have been with me all these years.
I'm doing this a long time.
So I really want to do
that big tour again.
And I don't know how,
how,
you know,
the kinds of rooms I'll do yet,
but I mean,
just on things that are on sale already,
they're going through the roof,
you know,
and the special has an ed,
but people know it's coming.
And you know,
ever since I did entourage,
I have this whole new audience and,
and they,
and I'll always get that.
When can I see a comedy special?
You're doing a comedy special.
So I really prepared for it.
I really took it serious.
You know,
when I see guys preparing for specials,
but just fucking around on stage,
that bothers me.
I'm like,
they all want to be superstars.
They all want to fill,
you know,
the staple center.
But nobody's putting
in the work to do that,
you know?
And I know you're a hard worker.
That's why I feel free
to tell you this stuff.
And I know you give
everything you got on stage.
I mean,
you know,
when,
it's funny,
when I was coming up
you weren't run around,
right.
So you know,
you had,
you had myself,
you had Sam Kennison who
was screaming his head off.
And then one night I walk
into the store and I'm like,
I'm seeing,
you know,
just style wise,
almost a blend of Kennison
and me coming through you,
but even more intense
when you would scream it.
That's why I love them.
I'm going,
who the fuck is this?
That the night I came in you were about,
you know,
deciding in your head.
I could tell if you want to just smash
this guy's skull in and I'm going now.
That's funny.
You know what I mean?
Because nobody came along since,
you know,
like I did an album called the data
left the died because Rick Rubin who
produced five of my albums,
you know,
he did like,
he,
he like he was the one that
brought wrap to the scene.
He's the one that bought the
black Crowes and you know,
bands like that.
I mean he produced,
you know,
rolling stone albums,
and he say to me,
you know it in the early nineties he'd go,
you're the end of comedy.
There's no way to go after this.
You know,
and then he has this maniac on stage.
I mean I came in in the
middle of your acts.
I had to like watch the way you walk,
you know,
because she would just,
this has got to be 15 years ago,
maybe even more and you know,
so you were so young and
just your face was beet red,
you know,
and I'm going,
I know this guy,
I didn't know your name cause I just
came walking in from the front door.
I go,
he's going to kill this
guy in the third row.
And I don't know what over,
it's a comedy show,
but that's the shit that makes me laugh.
And then one night,
Eleanor,
this is not even that long ago,
I was destroying somebody in,
you know,
in,
in the original room at the comedy
store and that's when you came up with,
I love dice mean.
And she told that to me.
I go,
does he really?
He,
she goes,
he just loves you.
And he loves when you get angry because
he knows you're really getting at,
it was one of my favorite things at
the comedy store to be in the back.
I would,
we be,
we'd be in the back talking and
someone would yell in the hallway,
dice got a heckler.
It's like we had a fish on,
you know,
it's like we got to now,
and we would all run in,
in the back and just watch
you just eviscerate people
when you would get really
mean when people look at you.
Because I would really see,
see I'm not fake on
stage and I'm emotional,
so fun doing like a great
bit that I know is great.
And in the middle of it,
you know,
I hear a guy yelling out little Bo peep.
Yeah,
I'm going to get angry at that person,
you know?
And uh,
you know,
it's not even about heckling that person.
It's about knowing I've mentally
hurt him for years to come.
But I like to know with great
timing and comedy scale,
you got to stay with it.
Yeah.
But it's like you really want to
hurt the person I'm going to cross.
You know what I mean?
Now it's at the level
where we throw people out,
you know,
which,
first I'll have the heckle fight.
Well,
you did that in Vegas.
You,
you threw a guy out,
the guy in the front row,
two minutes into the show,
the guy was so drunk he couldn't
even communicate with you.
You like,
this is not good.
And I can't deal with that.
It's like,
why that drunk?
I had a guy,
I was at a governor's a few months ago.
Do you remember this,
Valerie?
With the blind guy?
Yeah.
Okay.
So this guy is just drunk and
he's wearing dark sunglasses.
Just looking like a dice clone,
you know,
that guy's gotta be,
50,
you know,
or in his forties,
whatever.
So I'm going back and forth
with them a little bit,
you know,
I figured out,
I'll always give a person a chance,
but the guy now I get back into
the act and he starts in some more.
So you know,
you know,
you got pretty tough bounces there,
and I go,
do me a favor,
get rid of this fucking
asshole of a human being.
You know what I mean?
Just throw them the fuck out.
So now after the show,
Don Jamison was opening for me that night
and he would sell his t shirts at the
front of the club,
you know,
so he comes to the
dressing room and he goes,
you just missed the greatest
thing I ever saw in comedy and go,
why?
What happened?
He goes,
you know,
that guy you threw out,
it took number one for bounces.
He had like retarded strength.
He goes,
but he was blind,
you know,
and he was swinging his stick at them.
He,
he ran,
he tried to run.
And he smashed right into a wall and he
turned around and he was fighting these
guys and he was winning.
You know,
going,
he's coming back in the room,
he's going to kick dices ass.
I mean,
that's what a comedy show is today.
Who's going to kick somebody's ass?
And I'm going,
how the fuck did I know he's blonde.
You know what I mean?
The Guy,
you know,
I've had guys come to my show wearing
the glasses and the fingerless gloves.
How am I going to know the guy?
He's blind,
you know?
And then dragging them out of the room.
He was starting to fight them
on the way out of the room,
you know,
which is entertaining to me,
this way I get to laugh a little,
you know what I mean?
You know?
Why should the audience always be the
one to have a good laugh to make me
fucking laugh,
you know?
So when Don told me,
I went,
Don told me the story of the
blind guy really was laughing.
It was very enjoyable.
But the other side of me was I went to
throw him the guy out if I knew he was
blind,
that it,
you know,
how do you do that?
You know,
kicking a cripple that's a wheelchair.
So was he hacking on w he was just,
but it was,
it was drunk and it was,
you know,
it wasn't coherent stuff.
And I'm going,
okay,
ash,
whole face,
you know,
which is,
uh,
one of my newest Heco lines where,
you know,
if a guy's a real asshole,
I'll tag them with that
name and I'll keep going,
asshole face.
And then I start getting angry and I go,
I'm not saying you're an asshole.
I go,
I know you've been called that
a thousand times in your life.
Goes to the kind of person you are.
What I'm saying to you is,
I think you have a face that
resembles a fucking asshole.
And that's what I truly think of you.
You know Damn Shit that you wake up in
the middle of the night when you go to
take a leak.
No.
I'll tell you what happens
mentally when you say no,
no,
this is what happens with that c,
let's say it's a guy in
Vegas with his friends.
Hey asshole face.
You know,
so those friends that are with him now,
these buddies of 20 years,
you know that night they're
going to come on air.
So face let's go have a drink.
And it's funny the next day,
even maybe even a week later,
but three years later when the corner
house and the kids are picking up the
phone to go and put ass
off face on the phone,
that's when the guys call him.
Why did I ever say a
fucking word at that show?
Because now forever he's asshole face.
That's a multi tiered solution.
I like how you played that out,
but I really think about that stuff.
I go,
what would hurt in the long run?
That's like some humbling chest shit,
right?
Like if you call it,
I've heard you call people and say,
hey,
you're a fucking asshole.
They don't even hear it because
they've been called but to,
but to tag them and let them know they
have a face that resembles an ace.
No.
Even if they don't just give them that,
you know,
normally the ones I pick out has it.
And you know what I mean?
I really looked for a guy that ha,
I don't want to give a guy in
named that doesn't fit him.
You know what I mean?
So he's sort of Hash to
have a face that resembles,
that's heckler.
Herpes is what that's called.
Yeah.
It just keeps coming back to
haunt you because that's the fan.
That was another time,
you know,
it,
it's,
you know,
Max was with me and um,
this,
you know,
this guy was fucking with Eleanor
on stage and his girlfriend I think,
or his wife.
So I come on stage and the
minute he opened his mouth,
I'm like,
throw this mother fucker around.
Oh No.
I wasn't on stage.
And what happened was
I start yelling at the,
uh,
you know,
the promoters of the shot.
I go get that fucking guy out of the room.
If he's bad with ty,
he's not even gonna let me get started.
But it wasn't good enough for
me that they throw him out.
I come out the back door,
I'm going to fight the guy,
you know.
Well Eleanor is stolen stage,
you know,
so I figured there's a little time,
and my wife Wa was yelling at your phone,
is it my phone?
What?
Go fuck with these things.
I don't know how he,
unfortunately,
I think you've also told that story.
It's happy face,
happy face.
Yeah.
And uh,
wait,
let me shut this.
Who's happy things?
Uh,
he's,
he's with me for like 25 years already.
He's a,
he does security from it.
He's into what you're into,
you know,
with the fire.
He's got,
uh,
you know,
martial arts schools on the east
coast and his name's happy face.
Well,
it's names Mike Malandra,
you know,
but it's happy face.
Everybody calls him happy for it.
Yeah.
And you know,
cause I'll always like tried to smile
at a guy when he's throwing them out and
you know,
he's,
he's a pretty deadly guy.
And that's what I love
about him being happy face.
I mean it's a great name.
He got his job,
you know how he got to get love,
negative happy faces.
A great fucking West.
Also happy west as bad as good.
Well happy faces with me like 25 years.
And the way he got us the job was I would
work out in a gym in a Gold's gym in
Jersey and we would just
start talking and you know,
then we work out a little together
and he's happy faces about five,
seven,
you know.
But he's not that big,
But he would talk about
his martial arts school.
How his father taught him.
They both had the school,
you know,
and he,
like you know,
like a father,
like son,
he followed in his footsteps.
So He's standing between
the two owners of the gym,
which what animals?
These guys were like,
you know,
the type that bench
three 50 a hundred times,
you know,
the big guys.
So I said happy face.
They go,
you know,
with my shows,
I don't like,
you know,
we were talking about
him like working for me,
cause I had club Soda
Kenny who's like six,
five big,
you know.
And I said,
so I looked at happy face
like he's the sniper,
you know,
they'd never see him coming.
I go,
but we don't like to hurt anybody.
so what I'm going to do,
I'm going to try to get pissed,
Jill,
and you've got to stop
me without hurting me.
And this guy put me down.
My ass didn't even touch the ground.
That's how fast he moved.
But at first he's gone,
I don't want to touch you.
He goes,
I came to the Meadowlands to see,
you know,
he goes,
I can't,
you know,
I go,
well that's the game.
You can't hurt me.
That's it.
And he did this,
move,
this,
this move on me.
That just puts the department always
hurt you if you're resisting and hurt,
you get hurt.
Just scrambling.
That's right.
But he popped me down in that night.
He was working for me and that
was the beginning of happy face.
That's a nice name.
I like it.
Yeah.
And I love his temper.
When he gets mad.
It's a lot of fun to make them get angry.
You know,
it's funny talking about like,
cause he didn't like the
name Mike the Murderer.
So that's fascinating.
Well yeah,
he starts screaming about that.
Don't call me that,
you know,
it's a touchy situation,
you know.
You know what I'm calling,
it's just a name.
He but don't call me
that,
you know.
Yeah.
People don't want that murderous.
No,
but he's happy face for 25 years,
so he's happy.
But that's why he's calling me the comedy
store was always the worst place in
the world for heckling because there
was no crowd control whatsoever.
Nothing.
You would think.
Like when I,
when I lived in Boston
and we were at stitches,
stitches is when,
uh,
that's where I did my first open mic.
And uh,
I had,
uh,
been really inspired by you,
really inspired by a Kennison
and a few other guys.
And I was,
I was really like looking
forward to doing some,
you know,
trying to do some standup comedy.
And you think back then like what the,
what the face of comedy was
like and what it's like now.
Yeah.
See it's all like blank to me right
now and I'm not pitching on it,
but I don't find,
you know,
I'll flip around the channels,
just see if somebody is on,
stopped watching for a few minutes.
But like I say,
these guys don't put a lot into their,
um,
into dead snow.
There's nobody developing a persona,
you know?
And those are the kind,
you might not realize it,
but you'll have a persona.
You know what I mean?
People come to see Joe Rogan,
they know what they're getting,
you know,
but there aren't too many guys.
It's almost like,
like,
like white bread,
you know,
this,
there's no persona up there.
So even if the material's decent,
you know,
a lot of material has been done.
A lot of guys covered the same subjects.
I'd rather see a guy that's more
entertaining that I could go to.
You fucking believe what
he's doing up there.
That's the kind of act I like to see.
When we were in Boston and we were
starting out and we're like looking at the
face of comedy,
the comedy store was always Maca.
That was always like that fucking place
where you'd make the pilgrimage and
everybody goes see the,
these see this stage where you
performed the Kennison performance.
Richard Pryor and let her,
but when I got there and when I got there,
like I forget who was on
stage with some road hack.
Uh,
the,
the place was half fall and uh,
some guy's yelling out shit in the back
of the room and no one's kicking them
out.
Nobody.
And this was,
this was like my first experience at
the commerce body guards at the Dorman,
a comic.
Nobody wants to get into it.
Only Harris.
Pete Harris.
Pete would get down,
get down,
he would throw dudes out.
I went to a Tony Danza knock him out.
Oh really?
Yeah,
because you know how
condescending Harrison,
you guys,
Tony Danza box just wanted to come in.
Yeah.
Nicest.
Kobe.
You know,
Tom,
I don't know if you know,
but he's just this friendly guy,
kick ass,
you know.
And Harris gave him a hard time
and he put his hands on him.
Uh,
you know,
like you can't just walk in and he just
gave them one shot and he went flying
down the stairs.
Wow.
Really funny.
Poor,
really enjoyable.
Harris's such an angry
guy for whatever reason.
He's such an angry guy.
It took me a year to get even the
tiniest compliment from that guy.
Yeah,
that's it.
Negative,
negative.
Yeah.
He just left the world he liked,
just got on his motorcycle.
But I do have to say when
the guy gave you props,
it meant something,
you know,
I for some reason it did the back well,
it would like him to be a
little bit more fair with them.
You know what I'm saying?
What you know,
it's like getting a compliment from him
was like getting one from Mitzi for some
reason it was called what it is cause
he was always there and he saw everybody
before.
That's true too.
You know,
whether or not to be
impressed with you or not,
or whether or not you are
just bullshit in the crowd.
But he was also just negative,
but also the comedy store,
I think,
you know,
somebody like you would like it.
And myself was,
that was the bad boy comedy club.
It still is.
You know,
it's like you say it's a free for all.
You go over to the Improv,
which is a great club,
but it's,
everything is run at the comedy store.
Nobody even knows who's running things,
any madness.
And it was more madness
then than it is now.
I think it's probably a way better
managed now than it was back in the early
days.
But man,
it was insane.
But when I came along it was 94.
That's when I was first
started performing there.
And uh,
I just,
I was blown away,
but it was like the
place was like crackling.
It's like the magic of all those sets
in the walls and with the store you ever
noticed.
You could go there some nights,
you know,
the Sunday,
Monday nights,
and it's as fun as could be.
And crazy.
And then there were certain nights
when you come there like that.
And just the vibe is bad.
Just the wrong combination
of people that you go,
you know what I'm getting at here.
It's just that bad fucking vibe.
And then just other nights just insane.
Great.
Yeah.
It's an amazing club.
You know,
just the history.
I still love it.
I still love going there.
I still love going on the stage.
Yeah.
I can't go back because of the
falling out that I had with them.
I didn't know about that.
The dementia issue,
you didn't know,
but you're not allowed back courses.
I never went back.
I never would go back when they,
uh,
they banned me from that and I'm like,
you guys are out of your fucking mind.
Yeah.
But if he weren't banned then
you wouldn't be a comedy store.
Ma,
I got bandwidth for that Mitzi band.
Maybe once for my j Howard Marshall Joke.
I had this joke about,
uh,
about the old dude that,
that fucked and Nicole Smith and
I was one of my favorite jokes.
It's a quick joke.
She hated it.
It was just about,
you know,
that everyone was saying,
oh,
it's such a,
it's so sad to watch his poor old man,
you know,
and like,
like he's,
he's getting,
he's getting robbed and this
woman's just here for his money.
And I'm like,
don't you think he knows
that was 90 years old.
He made $1 billion from scratch.
You know,
chances are he's a tad crafty.
Like how do you want him to die?
And then it was this whole death scenario,
like on you go off to
a bunch of dirty shit.
And I love the bit,
but it was a lie.
It was about old people.
She did not like it.
And I think she banned me once for that.
She banned me wants or something else too,
but it will only take a little time.
My kids were even banned from there.
I had
a thing with Paula years ago,
like when I first broke up with my wife,
you know,
I'd always bring my kids to the
comedy store at night and you know,
Eleanor would hang with them,
you know,
so one night,
I mean Dylan,
who's now 18,
you know,
it was only 11 you know,
and you know,
I'm seeing,
I'm pulling in the comedy pulley had a
hamburger joint when he was 12 years old
at the Westwood comedy store.
So I know Paulie grown
up since he's that age.
So he goes,
how many times I got to tell you,
don't bring your fucking kid in here.
You know?
And I was like,
I already said that like that.
But he was standing there,
my kid was there,
so I go,
Dylan,
I forgot,
I think he was with Steve Simone.
I go,
Steve,
take them outside.
You know,
I go,
you know,
like I was going to have
to hurt him at that moment,
you know,
but I didn't want,
but I,
I got,
I didn't get physical,
you know,
you can't do that stuff,
but poorly told his mother
that I threw a glass at him.
So she banned me and the kids,
you know,
my kids were,
Ben did 11 and 15 from the comment,
which is so great.
I go and my son Max loved
it because he understood it.
He was old enough to understand it.
And uh,
and then one night Mitzi comes in and
Illinois was sitting with a and saying,
no,
that's not what happened.
I was right in the
kitchen when it happened.
He didn't throw a glass of poorly.
She goes,
if anything,
he would have caved
his skull and you know,
he just threw the glass in
the garbage on his way out.
And she,
you know,
her voice,
she's,
well,
I knew that Andrew went
through something like that.
You know,
he wouldn't go to that level.
Yeah.
You wouldn't know.
I would never,
I was never,
you know,
that's not what I do.
I can see you hitting somebody.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
but I can't hit somebody
unless they try to hurt me.
You know,
it was more like I just laid into him
for it and on the way out of the kitchen,
the back door,
like through my glass
and it broke on the wall,
you know,
and the other garbage can there.
But Paulie was out in the hallway.
He was nowhere near it.
But it was,
you know,
and we made up,
of course,
we're friends today and you know,
we laugh about all the nonsense,
but you know,
it's just a crazy place.
I mean sometimes tend to
show you would love this.
You weren't even out there yet.
This is like,
I'm talking like 86 87 so me and Kennison
would be the last acts of the night.
Every night she'd put us on back to back.
And it was either he went on first or I
went on first and like to end the show.
Sometimes if he'd go on first,
you know,
I'd be on stage.
And you know,
once he'd get bored with it,
he'd throw a chair at me on stage and
then the whole fight would happen on the
stage with called the would jump and
you would just see who's ever in the
audience because the
audience is terrorists.
They don't know what's going on.
They don't know.
You know,
I'm falling over the front tables
knocking people love and people are just
running out of the place.
Like what the fuck is this?
Like all breaks loose.
There was so many great fake fights at
the comedy store cause that's the one
thing comics lift to do.
We love being children.
Todd Barron,
Tom like the king
of that Shit.
Let's talk to him last night about you.
He loves you to death and uh,
he's like,
you should bring it up.
How he used to,
did he used to go on the
road with you or did you
dawn,
I would put don in whatever I was in,
I would put him in,
like,
we wound up doing this,
this crazy frank Stallone movie in Ixtapa,
you know,
uh,
Mexico and we were stuck
there for like five weeks.
And of course I made,
I made dawn do like Alfred
Hitchcock and the movie,
there was no call for Alfred Hitchcock,
but I talked to producers into it,
you know,
and that's where he actually hurt,
hurt his foot.
You know how he's got like a bad foot.
Yeah,
he hurt his foot.
Well,
what happened with don?
He always wants to fight me,
you know,
so,
so one day,
you know,
he starts in with me on the set and
it's all these Mexican crew members that
don't even understand English.
And he puts his foot like there was a
hole in the ground and he wouldn't go to
the hospital after to fix it,
you know?
So to this day,
like he just moves the
wrong way and he's crippled,
you know,
he just falls down.
And it was funny.
What happened was I went back to a
Madison Square Garden in 2000 and it was
Don's job at the time to come there
because he really wants to see it with my
wife and my sons.
So he was the problem on the plane because
what happened was he's walking down
an aisle and the foot goes and he's,
you know,
Don's emotional,
so he's screaming,
laying on the floor and the flame scaring,
scaring the entire flight,
you know,
and then they get him into a
chair and the foot felt better,
you know,
so it was that the cops were at the
airport to question him and I go,
you a job was to just bring them here.
That was the gift.
You get to fly for nothing
and get a hotel room,
bring them in and you cause a
problem on the fucking airline.
But that's done.
You know,
that's who he is.
You think he was his practical jokes?
No.
He was
laying at norms.
No,
no,
no.
Really goes,
his foot really goes,
is it a broken foot?
Is it a ligament?
I'm sure he'd like chips,
something in his ankle and he
just wouldn't go to the house.
He goes,
well,
they're going to do to me,
you know,
he turns into this baby,
you know?
Oh yeah.
And he would do the road with me,
you know,
and I had it when he
would do the road with,
I would just take them with
me when he would do the road.
I had a,
at that time I had Eddie Griffin with me.
I had,
yeah.
So Eddie Griffin was like the real open,
you know.
And so what would happen is I'd
give Don 10 minutes right upfront.
So we'd be on a big tour bus,
traveling the country.
And one time he's on
the bus and he's like,
you know how he gets down on himself,
you know,
like almost like that he's
not crying with tears,
but I'm going down.
It's because the crowd doesn't
respond the way he wants.
You know,
cause he would come out singing,
tie a yellow ribbon,
you know,
with,
with the music over it and
get the crowd clapping.
And so now the song ends and
then he goes into another one.
It'll go into like Copa Cabana.
So now he's on the bus
complaining about that.
Go Don,
it's your 10 minutes after they get the
joke of who you are that you're this
fucking goofball.
Well now where are the jokes?
You know?
And he would go,
well,
you know,
I went into the other,
so I go,
they don't want to hear another,
you already did the big,
you had them clap.
Now they've got a clap
to Barry Manilow singing,
you know,
Copa Cabana,
who gives a fuck?
You know what I mean?
And nobody gives a fuck.
You create the character,
you just fucking big goofball
and now give him jokes,
you know?
And,
but we had a lot of fun and then that
would be another rumble on the bus.
Now it's in jumping on me and
trying to kill me on the bus.
Yeah,
he's in his life is constant
theater with that guy.
I didn't,
did I,
that's who I hang out with every single
day from midnight to about 4:00 AM Tom
Barrett.
And,
you know,
it was hysterical with the movie.
We did an extensive,
but uh,
date they want them to stay
and film for longer than I,
I wanted to be there,
you know,
and I'm gone.
I gotta get Outta here.
I got gigs,
I got to dose.
So they promised me a lot of,
a lot of money,
you know,
in like cash and in Taiwan,
through the whole shoot is going,
they're never giving it to you.
You've got to get it now.
I got done,
they're going to pay me.
We made a deal.
That's it.
You know,
Eh,
you know,
and you know,
the,
it was a crazy set,
you know,
I mean,
I never went through anything
like this in a film ever.
You know what went on in those five weeks.
And so he's gone,
you know,
two to five weeks.
I've got to hear how
they're not going to pay me,
you know,
he's just on me that the,
and of course they give me the
money and dawn had a tape it up,
you know,
all over my body.
Like that movie midnight express it.
You Willing?
Yeah.
Because you know,
it was a part of Mexico that we actually
thought that the director was going to
happen.
He stopped at the airport,
you know,
so you know,
with thinking,
all right,
how am I going,
cause you're not allowed more
than like $10,000 in cash.
And this was a lot of money,
you know?
So he was taping it with this
like paper tape to my chest,
to my thoughts.
You know,
that when I got home,
you know,
and when we're going through the airport,
I'm gone,
they're going to stop me,
I'm going to be in jail and whoever
stops and he's going to be rich,
you know,
it's that simple.
But they didn't stop us.
And now I get home and I take off my shirt
and my wife sees all this money taped
to my chest and she's going,
what is that?
You know?
And I'm going,
no,
they paid me.
You know,
that's how they pay you in Mexico,
you know?
But Tom was just so sure
they're not paying for them.
It was just crazy.
It was,
I wouldn't eat,
we only had one meal a day because
everybody on the set was getting sick.
You know,
everybody was going to the hospital
and it and all we had every day was um,
we went to the same restaurant
about four o'clock every day.
We had pasta with sauce,
garlic bread and Coca Cola would purified
ice and we wouldn't eat until the next
day at the same time.
Cause we figured we'd make it the middle
of the day because we're only getting
that one meal.
We're not eating any of the food there.
Wow.
Yeah.
And he lost like 30 pounds.
Fine.
He's,
he's gone.
I got to eat something,
you know,
he's going,
this is ridiculous step.
We're not eating food,
you know,
but everybody's fallen at the waist side.
What are we going to do?
We got no chick.
This is survival.
My friend.
Those be movie sets can
be very fucking sketchy.
And it was for a long time.
Was it five weeks of the same food?
But I'm a kid.
I could do that.
I could eat the same
thing every single day.
But you want it like twice a day,
but the restaurant would
close like nine at night,
so we'd have to wait until the next day
at four o'clock to have the next meal.
Wow.
Bottled water,
you know?
And that was it.
Bottled water and pasta once a day.
What's the name of this movie?
It was called the good life.
It never came out,
you know?
And I always talked to frank Stallone.
He always says he should release
like pieces of it on the Internet.
Yeah.
It was the craziest thing,
you know?
Uh,
I wanted it to be a comedy.
Frank Stallone wanted it to be a drama,
you know,
because,
I would tell the producers,
I go,
you know,
it's really a funny movie,
and comedy cells,
right?
So when frank would do a scene,
he'd come over to the director and go,
you know,
how was that?
And he goes,
well,
it was very dramatic,
you know,
and he's gone,
well,
it's supposed to be a drama.
And he goes,
well,
I think it should be funnier.
And he goes,
but the movie's a fucking drama.
Like,
so he was flipping out at,
we had a big fight over that movie,
but uh,
but the producers now want
to just be like a comedy.
Dennis Hopper's in it.
It was supposed to be,
you know what it was supposed to be.
It was supposed to be
Goodfellas on a golf course.
So Dennis Hopper,
Dennis Hopper was in it,
but it was filming.
Really.
Can you find it anywhere?
It's snow would be,
but it doesn't,
yeah.
It's not online,
but no one put it online.
But David Carradine was in it too.
Yeah.
A lot of people were in the Angelos
investors to the loans in it.
That's hilarious.
And he never made it.
You should never know shit to
Netflix or something like that.
You'll make it.
It's,
well,
it's not my movie to sell,
but you know,
it just wound up,
the whole time in Ixtapa was drama,
you know?
But it,
the movie's hysterical.
You know,
it was just movie sets.
I've only been on one.
I've been on well to be movie movies.
But you know what happened?
We had a good director at the beginning,
and then the producer who was an attorney
fired the director and he decided to
direct a no.
So now what happens is,
this is where it starts
going a little crazy.
Uh,
and I,
you know,
I can't play golf.
I hate fucking golf.
I don't have patients to
hit a one little ball,
you know,
of course the park,
whatever,
you know.
So I wasn't really good
at playing the golf,
you know,
so we would make it that
they make fun at me,
but I had some like golf
material at the time.
We had talked about hating golf.
So the,
the,
this new director makes me do some of
that material on like the mass to shot,
like on a crane.
So he goes,
I want you to do that
monologue every time,
you know?
And I go,
no,
but I'm not doing that monologue
every time I did a few,
cause you asked me to do
it in the mass of the shot,
just so you get some talking.
And he goes,
no,
I want you to do it.
I go,
that's my material from my act.
I don't want to do it.
You know,
you're not paying me for it all year.
And he goes,
you'll do what I say.
I'm not going to do a fucking thing.
You say,
I go and don't ever tell
me what to do again.
Ever in front of the camera.
Which Dom Barris is falling down laughing
as he's making a little documentary
movie with my camera,
because I was always filming.
He did.
He literally say,
you'll do as I say,
yeah,
whoever lands.
And he goes and he,
and he says,
if you don't like it,
you could leave.
So I said,
okay,
I'll leave.
I go done.
Let's go.
And I had calypso to Kenny.
They,
I go,
let's say.
He goes,
well,
my attorneys will be in touch.
I go,
asshole,
you told me to leave to say
you don't want me in the movie.
If I don't want to do my own
material and I don't want to do it,
so don't fucking tell me what to
do and I'll stay and that's it.
You know?
And what don loved is,
no matter what the guy did,
you know,
for his main profession,
he goes,
you're telling you a director,
the guy that supposed
to tell you what to do,
don't ever tell me what to do again,
but that is only job right
now is telling you what to do.
I go,
yeah,
but you heard what went down,
you know,
and he agreed with it.
And then I decided to
direct part of the special,
it's not the special the movie.
And um,
cause I come to the set one
day and it's like 110 degrees.
And this guy,
you know,
the guy directing it was,
he had a funny character.
He was very low keyed with a sombrero
cause it was Mexico and it was always hot.
And I go,
uh,
what are we doing today?
And he goes,
I don't know.
You know,
and I go,
do you want me to set the shot up?
And he goes,
would you please,
this is the director now.
He goes,
just tapped out.
I just want to finish
the movie and go home.
And that's how he would talk.
That's like an impression of the guy.
So now I'm directing,
I'm directing the movie and
that was a scene I directed.
This was great because I was like a
little at war with frank still at the time
on the set.
So I was shooting a scene that I needed
Don Barris for and now I decided to club
soda.
Kenny will be in the movie also,
you know.
So frank is shooting a scene where he's
like playing a guitar in his underwear,
talking to some girl he was
with in bed the night before.
So I come in there and
I take the sound guys,
I'm like,
come on,
just come with me.
So now I got the sound guy.
So he winds up shooting the soul scene
that he's doing and he doesn't know,
he doesn't have sound.
And all of a sudden
coming from this house,
you hear him screaming,
he tucked the fucking sound guys,
you made me do all these takes and
we don't even have fucking sound.
And then the director's going,
well dices directing a scene right now,
you know?
And he goes,
why the fuck is he directing anything?
It's not his movie to direct.
I mean,
people were having,
and then we crashed the golf carts,
which I got in trouble for.
I played chicken with the,
you know,
Peta Dobson,
he's an actor.
No.
Um,
he's been in a lot of stuff anyway,
so it's me and Dobson,
we're good friends and decide to
play chicken with the golf carts.
And I turned at the last second and my
golf cock gets completely destroyed and
frank goes flying out of it
because he's with me going,
what are you doing as what?
Going towards each other and I'm
going to just stick with me on this.
He goes,
I don't want to stick with you.
Stopped driving,
you know,
but we wouldn't stop driving.
And I turned and they smash him.
I,
so now I'm not allowed
to be in the golf cart.
Chicken.
Yeah.
Chicken to see who turns first,
you know,
and then we're having sword
fights with the golf clubs.
I mean,
it was ridiculous what was going on.
You know,
Beverly Deangelo's in the movie,
uh,
frank pressures in the Moodle
is your war with Frank Stallone?
What was that?
I believe the movie should be a comic,
you know,
so I started doing like an impression
of him on screen cause I could do him
really well the way he
stands and you know,
so now he sees the final kind and he goes,
what are you doing behind me?
You know,
I go an impression of you.
He goes,
you're not supposed to be
doing an impression of me.
I'm,
I'm the leader of the gang.
But it's funny.
And he goes to put the movies not funny,
you know?
And of course we all made
up if you know movie,
you know,
never came out,
make up with everybody
you make up with Paul.
You made up a dark guy.
Yeah.
Because it's more fun
to have your friends.
Are you going to make
up and laugh about it?
You and dom Irrera ever going to make up,
you know,
it's not that I'm even like
mad at a guy like I rare.
Right.
You know,
he's just stupid.
You know what I mean?
You know,
I really don't.
I like both of you.
I wish you guys would,
uh,
work that out.
What does nothing to work out,
you know,
just call them stupid.
I'd say you have an issue.
Well,
calling somebody stupid in saying,
I don't like the guy at
two different things.
Here we go.
He's a great comic.
I think he's a great comedian,
but you know,
he's,
he's just too bitter for me.
You know what I mean?
You know,
he,
when you and him,
I've always had like
this,
it's agonizing.
Always had it with you used to,
you know,
I came in to Philly
years ago and you know,
I would headline the
comedy factory outlet,
you know,
so they would have him open the shows,
and he would look at my character like
Italian rather than just a Brooklyn guy.
And you know,
you know,
my real name's Andrew Clay Silverstein.
And I went to Andrew dice clay,
you know,
so when like,
we won the same Rodney special,
you know,
and he,
he just got fucking jealous that my
career went through the roof and,
you know,
and he didn't,
you know.
And the funny thing about that was,
I might've even talked about this on your
show that he would've been the perfect
guy.
You know,
when I was doing the arenas,
you know,
to open those shows,
cause people did like,
I'm on this special,
but like I said,
not everybody becomes a mega star.
It just doesn't happen.
Not everybody becomes the fucking Beatles.
I'm sorry.
You know?
But he's a great comic.
And because he had,
you know,
he started going on radio shows
and say in my real last name.
And I'm like,
what's the problem?
A,
a Jew from Brooklyn can't be a tough good
looking guys that the fucking problem,
you know,
unless I'm Italian.
Well,
well the,
the name clay,
where'd that come?
Well,
that's just my middle name.
Andrew Clay Silverstein.
Oh,
well my parents got it.
So,
uh,
when you decided to just go as dice clay,
why did you decide to do that?
Andrew dice clay?
Yeah.
Why'd you seem was mean?
I mean,
you know what the original
name was when I go on stage is,
um,
this was funny because when I,
you know,
my original act was like impressions.
I'll just put it to you that way.
You know,
doing Travolta and Stallone and
Jerry Lewis Travolta isn't Sam,
you're Travolta is the
best or vault on earth?
No one,
no one nails it.
Well,
the thing about Travolta is that,
you know,
he had those Brooklyn characters and it,
we were similar looking
when I was 17 years old,
you know,
and I was just able to do them,
I was,
I could turn it to Vinnie,
Bob Marino,
like,
all right,
so you asked me,
uh,
Vinnie,
you know,
where's your homework?
Vinnie?
Where's your homework?
What?
That was the act.
That was the whole thing.
No,
no,
no
words.
You know,
I did my homework book,
but my dog ate it.
I couldn't believe it.
You know,
and I would do all these Travolta it,
but after the impressions,
when I came to the comedy store,
after I did,
I got a shot on Don [inaudible] rock
concert and I did that whole act,
but now it was about the acting
thing and I was thinking,
well,
nobody's going to buy me
to do Travolta wrist alone.
I got to develop my own stage persona.
Do you know what kind of nuclear
arsenal of a joke you have in your,
in,
in your wheel house,
if you just did it with you doing an
impression of Travolta and have some
massage bit.
Do you know with that impression
how good that bit would be?
I know you don't want to do it and
ad luck at of a courtesy to Travolta.
I know you think he's very talented.
You don't do jokes about him,
but my God,
what a fucking crushing
bit you would have.
Yeah.
But I,
I know what compression is really good.
And then with the,
the situation is so ridiculous.
Him just wanting to get
jerked off by all these guys,
him saying,
let me massage you.
You're like,
it's,
the whole thing is great.
I mean,
it's right for comedy.
I'm not hating the guy.
I love him.
Well,
did you let him in the dig month?
Thumbs into your neck?
A little
good.
See you got a little crick,
but I,
you know what don't,
why are you telling me?
You telling me that you pretending
to massage a guy and then stolen,
then sliced says lowered.
That feels pretty good.
No,
I got a sense of humor about it.
I just feel he's been through a lot.
He's been through love,
but he's also dished out a lot.
He's one of our greatest stars,
so I can't do it.
He's,
that's hilarious.
He's a great actor,
no doubt about it.
But he's also a freak life
getting jerked up by dude's.
There's no question about that either.
That seems to be a reoccurring
theme and I ain't hating the guy,
man.
You should be able to do
whatever the fuck you want to do.
You know what it is?
There's a lot of guys who
were blown just cause he's,
but that's what the,
you know,
the problem with women were maybe that's
why he went to the guys I think just
don't know how to jerk.
I think he's a freak,
you know what I mean?
Is that it?
You try to teach them,
you know what I mean?
Some girls just seem to have uh,
uh,
born in ability to do it correctly,
so girls just get it.
Yeah.
You know,
squeeze hard.
Alright folks telling me to say here.
Your thing is my wife is squeeze harder.
Going to hey,
send us.
I got the legs wrapped behind
every years saddled down.
Yeah.
Look at him Mr. Date and not
by the hair of Chinny Chin.
Chin can get a date,
you know,
but no,
I love Travolta.
I let you know,
I can only do impressions of,
of,
of the people in film that I really love.
Right.
It's too bad he can't do it.
Well,
I just didn't see it though.
I gave you a little less time.
I want to do it.
That's it.
Yeah.
I mean,
I could come up with it,
trust me,
but I got to leave the guy alone.
That's a beautiful thing.
I would not leave him alone.
Even if we were tight.
Can we do Travolta?
No,
no.
You do any impressions?
I can do a couple.
I want to see one of your shows now.
I'm not even kidding.
I'll,
I'll send you my special.
I'll gift it to you.
I'll give the five bucks.
I'm willing to pay.
You know what I mean?
You know,
just,
you know,
I got a heart for people.
That's what it is.
I understand.
You know?
So even like when I rare,
rare,
like you were saying,
you know what I mean?
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't hate the guy.
You know,
they're,
they're all guys I don't like,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
I mean,
just don't like for many reasons.
Right.
His own,
you know,
jealousy would overcome him I guess,
but he missed out on the
greatest Gig in the world,
you know,
doing these arenas because
he is an Italian from Philly.
I mean,
I did the three times,
you know what I mean?
And he would have been
great in those rooms.
So I would book Lenny Clarke
and Lenny Clarke wound up,
I'll never forget,
I did the universal amphitheater
and then he calls me up and he goes,
you know,
can I have some people come to the show?
And I'm going,
Leonie,
that's what it's all about.
Like why wouldn't you be able to have
people come to the show at 6,000 people,
you know?
Right.
And he winds up,
I don't know if you know
Lenny clocks all great,
but he,
they gave him a sitcom.
He got to sit down that night
and that didn't work out.
And he wound up on the Sitcom with,
uh,
what was it,
a Frazier,
you know,
Frazier,
I think.
Yeah.
Where he played a cop now,
wasn't that he wasn't on
the channel layer catch up,
but didn't put it might've been that.
Well,
you could look red pen to something.
You're running the panel.
Do the IMD for Lenny Clarke,
by the way.
Larry Clark.
No,
but Lenny Clarke wound
up with a huge Korea.
One of the funniest guy
and it was nice to know,
but I'm telling you,
it was that night that it
all came together for him.
Lenny Clarke gave me some
great fucking advice too.
Like my second time ever
getting paid to perform.
I opened up for Lenny,
this guy that I was working for,
norm norm,
the who was booking gigs in western
Massachusetts or these little one night
bars.
Yeah,
there's a place called js and Pittsfield,
Massachusetts and I got
to open up for lending.
This is after Lenny had been on
HBO and I got to go and my car,
it was a funny moment because,
uh,
his brother has a great guy but still
books a club called giggles and saw Mike
Clark is the shit.
He's just a great,
great fucking guy.
I never met him,
but I know he's a Greg.
He gives me advice.
It's reputation.
He's like power.
You're pretty funny,
but you're going to have to
clean it up a little bit.
Talking to the right ones.
Dad,
Madonna bit,
you know,
that one is just too much.
I,
you know,
it was just saying like for his rooms,
like where I would work.
But then when he comes off stage
kid that was fucking hilarious.
Holy Shit.
That fucking Madonna bid was fucking hot.
Is
that heavy Boston accent and Mike's like,
I just got told done telling
them to stop doing that bit
there cat cat show.
It wasn't John Lennon here
and she also did Lenny.
I Lenny up lending,
I should know that because it was next
door to us when we were filming news
radio.
He was over there.
He fucking,
he said that John Lara QED guy was a Twat.
He would just say how fucking
horrendous it was to work with that guy.
Yeah.
But he took great.
Lenny was,
Lenny was a top notch stand up like before
he was buddies are all the guys that
were on the Rodney special.
So you had Lenny clock,
you had uh,
you know,
they had to fill a spot.
So he put Barry Sobel and now I saw,
look Barry syllabub one point in
time was pretty fucking funny.
See,
it was pretty fucking funny.
He's a funny guy,
but you know,
when we did the Rodney special,
you know how he was baseball jacket.
So he shows up with a motorcycle jacket.
All right?
A blacklight and he's going
on like a two before me.
It was Lenny than
then Carol Lee for them,
myself.
Then Bill Hicks,
uh,
IRA and Bob Schimmel.
And so he comes in wearing a
motorcycle jacket and he goes,
this is what I'm wearing
on the show tonight.
So I'm like,
all right,
another jerk off.
Cause I didn't know him well,
you know,
and I go over to Rodney,
I go look with the guys wearing Rodney.
And Rodney goes,
yeah,
so what,
you know,
I go,
well,
he wants to wear it on the show.
And then Rodney caught it.
You know,
he's gone,
Barry,
come in,
man.
You know what I mean?
He goes,
what are you going to wait on the show?
And I'm standing right there.
He goes,
well,
I'm going to wear this jacket.
And Rodney goes,
if you hit a jacket,
man,
you're not on the show.
Okay,
dice,
where's the leather?
You know?
And of course Barry took out his little
baseball jacket and that was the end of
that.
Do you think he was trying
to do it until like,
you know what,
you know when I prepared,
you know,
just like I'm talking
about my special now,
right.
I'm really prepared,
you know,
I'm not going to do a half ass job
when I'm up there and when that Rodney
special,
you know about,
I had about six months to get ready for
that and every night I'd go on at the
comedy store.
I wouldn't care if it was too
fucking people in the crowd.
I'm rehearsing,
I'm rehearsing the act.
That's it.
Joke to joke to joke,
you know Halloween,
there's dom,
I rare but just fucking
around on stage and I'm like,
these guys just don't get it.
Because I knew when I would be in front
of that camera that the only thing I
needed to worry about was playing
the people and the people at home.
I didn't want to think about the act.
I want them to be on automatic
pilot because your nerves
get to you and you want
to do the performance.
Now,
and these guys would just
fuck around at the store.
They wouldn't rehearse it,
you know?
And then they show up to do the
special and everybody's nervous.
And I'll never forget,
I walked from the Regency Hotel,
you know,
I just want it to feel New York and I
was in my outfit for the Rod and I'm
wearing a belt buckle,
you know this fucking big,
you know the song.
And I come walking into the club,
I got the glasses on and Rodney goes,
had he,
he,
he's like,
how do you feel man?
You know,
Rodney,
right?
And I go tonight,
they pay,
they pay tonight.
They get disciplined.
And Rodney tonight,
Dave,
hey,
okay man,
you're ready
tonight.
They're going to get disciplined.
Did you hear that?
And he just got such a kick out of it,
you know?
And when I went on,
it was like,
just kill them first show out of the box.
I loved it.
Or I need did that,
that Rodney had those specials and
introduce so many fucking comedian.
Well,
you know what,
that's,
if I do more as far as comedy specials,
that's what I want to do.
Now I want to put guys on that.
I think a great go around the country,
find the best know that's a great
and deliver those guys to America.
That's a great idea.
You know,
and you know,
I spoke to showtime,
they were into it.
You know,
it's,
but first I gotta do this,
you know,
and really I think people are just
to be fucking thrilled with this.
You know,
I was thrilled with the end result.
La Rocs just rocks the room,
which was a little scary to me
because when I saw the audience,
you know,
you know my boy just like,
like comics now that you got,
I think we used 18 cameras,
you know,
for the shoot.
So you know,
you know what I'm talking about.
Just the pressure of,
you know,
deuce a director,
all the people involved in the special.
And you know,
my kids came out,
you know,
Eleanor introduced them and they just
rocked the room and the crowd went nuts
because I'm worried that they're
not going to let them get started.
You know what I mean?
And they just rock that.
I'm so proud of them.
And they're actually going to be
at the whiskey on January 12th.
So people that want to see a,
a great band that's breaking La Rocs
could go to the whiskey on the 12th of
January.
It's always hard to get yourself into
a normal performance mode when you're
doing a special,
you know,
it's like,
it's when all the,
everything's riding on this one night,
you've got two shows to get it right.
Like sometimes the pressure
can be overwhelming and
you want to know something.
I only wanted to do one.
Uh,
and you know,
it was the people at showtime
that was smart enough to go,
no,
you're doing too.
You know,
and they were right because I fucked
up a few times in the first one.
Yeah.
It's,
it's always hard to just,
I wasn't nervous.
I was,
I was excited about it though.
You know,
it's the nervous excitement,
you know,
and then you get that first
laugh and you just loosen up.
Yeah.
But I was just so prepared.
I mean,
like you said,
you came to,
uh,
you know,
Vegas and saw the show
and saw me working on it.
And you know,
Vegas crowds aren't as great
as crowds around the country,
you know?
And that's another thing I like.
So it felt like the comedy store,
you know,
because in Vegas there's a
lot of variables going on.
This gambling,
drinking,
fighting with the check over,
losing the fucking money.
Now you were to show 10 at night,
you know,
and you're not even in
the mood for that show.
Yeah.
You know,
so the crowd,
you'd never get that full amped
up crowd that you would get.
Like when you're on the
road doing a concert,
you know that they're just
coming for the concert.
So when I got to Chicago and you know,
I hear the crowd before you even
come on that doing the dice,
dice,
I'm gone.
All right,
this is the real deal now.
So yeah,
I fucked up a couple of times in
the first taping of it and you know,
and then I got angry.
It became dice mean,
you know,
for the second show.
And it just,
I just delivered the way I knew I can.
One of the things that helped me,
and this is I think would help you to uh,
doing a podcast helps you
launch stage tremendously.
You get so used to talking to people.
You get so used to doing things
like live that when we do,
when I did these,
uh,
the special in,
Atlanta,
I,
there was the most natural I'd ever felt
being on stage because the Tabernacle I
had always had a problem with
that we're like going on.
When I was taping something,
I'd be like Steph and tight
and was just like never see.
You
were really happy with the
outcome of your performance.
Forget it was 100%.
How I always am a,
it was 100% like you even
said it while I was on stage.
I was like,
this is the most relaxed
I've ever been doing.
One of these things cause I didn't
because she was so prepared,
so prepared.
I'd put a lot of lot
of sets in to prepare,
a lot of writing in to prepare.
I had,
I had all the material like
completely down and but it was the,
this,
the audience is so fucking enthusiastic.
It's like that's what it ate.
Yeah.
They're so fun and like,
like I said,
that's where we do parallel because
we both draw crazy audiences.
Yeah.
You know people that are really
out for the hardcore comedy,
you know what I mean?
So you really delivered it then.
Well I am so happy that there's still
guys out there that are doing anything
controversial because I think this is
such a strange time when it comes to
comedy.
You know,
there's been so many
from the tosh thing too,
the Tracy Morgan thing too,
you know,
just fill in the blank of every,
any comedian that says anything.
The Gilbert Godfrey thing,
when he got in trouble for a lot of shit,
it's like at a,
at a certain point in time,
it's like we're going to,
if you keep going down this super ultra
sensitive fucking stupid path yet,
then there'll be no fun,
no comedy.
And by the way,
you're just saying what you don't like.
Okay.
You're saying you don't like it.
Well,
fucking don't listen.
It's really simple.
If you're not into what a guy
like Tracy Morgan would say,
or a guy like you would say,
well then don't fucking listen.
No,
no one's read it.
Hiring you to,
you can't tell me that it's bad.
You can't tell me that it's real.
You know,
it's a joke.
He's a fucking commit.
That shouldn't be,
you know,
it's like I said,
these comics are being put on trial.
Right.
You know,
and um,
you know,
there's even a bit that,
I do where I use the fag word,
but it's,
and the last thing I did it,
I did a,
an interview for a rolling
stone like three weeks ago.
And,
you know,
the guy asked me why I used the word fag,
and I said,
well,
did you listen to the whole?
And,
and he listened to the whole show,
he watched the whole show.
And I said,
do you see where I go with the bit?
What I'm really doing
by the end of that bit?
Is it sticking up for the gay
community is what I'm doing it,
it winds up about like,
you know,
when the guys were running,
try enough for president,
whatever.
And um,
so it's about the whole marriage thing.
You know,
I don't,
I don't want to do the bid on the end,
you know,
but that's what the bits about I go.
And if I would say,
you know,
catch gay rather than catch fag,
I go,
fig is a funny word.
You know what I mean?
And for people that don't like it,
well don't watch my shell,
but it's funny and
that's who I am on stage.
But if you're going to
talk about anything,
talk about what the bit really,
you know,
turns into,
not,
not a word.
Have you ever done anything,
any year old material that you
look back now and you're like,
oh,
I wouldn't do that today.
I wouldn't say that.
I really don't have many regrets on the,
uh,
you know,
I don't use too much of it in a special,
I do a couple of classic bits.
That's what I call them.
You know,
like today on a,
I was on good morning La and you know,
they played like some of this
midget bit that I've done for years.
But these are the new fans.
So you'd give them some of the
classic stuff you give them the,
the mother goose.
But other than that,
you know,
98% new act,
I've updated,
you know,
how I feel about different things.
And you know,
like I said,
we're living in a different world.
Technology,
we're living in a world where,
you know,
women today a brought up on porn,
God forbid they don't have a,
you know,
a profile shot.
It,
I bleached out ass,
hold on on the website or whatever.
They feel that not happening,
you know,
so,
so everything is new,
but it's got that,
you know,
real heavy bite to it and it's got the
anger that I like to bring to stage.
I mean,
I couldn't do it like you.
I mean when,
when I see you screaming up there,
I had a couple of screaming
he is but not as intense.
Like that's what,
that's what would make me
sit down and watch you.
I wanted to see how long can he scream,
how long can he put that energy out?
And you could back then you were gone
like two hours you could do and just like,
oh,
he loves it.
You know,
it was almost like,
it was,
it was more about,
it was almost like you're
doing a verbal workout,
you know what I mean?
You know,
it wasn't like,
all right,
I do a,
B,
c,
d and I'm done.
You would just go and I'm going kind of,
and what is this guy taking to that?
Anything like I'm watching you today,
you know,
um,
talk about like the different vitamins
and everything that it's on and I'm gone.
He's taken something
that could really make a,
I'm thinking maybe I should take some
of those fucking vitamins because you
could really go for a long time.
Yeah.
Volume.
It's not just about I'm taking vitamins.
It's definitely about what you eat.
It's really important.
No,
but I mean the energy,
that's what I love because you know,
when somebody is putting
out that kind of energy,
it's watchable.
We didn't have,
that's a good point that
you brought up earlier.
We didn't,
uh,
touch back on with the,
the idea that there's something wrong
with you if you're moving around or like
putting out a lot of effort.
There was a time in comedy where guys
like Dan and respect anybody who didn't
just stand still and just say it with
your words and it's like what you will,
why would you lose like that performed?
Like I would see a guy,
like maybe Jim brewer is a good example,
was really physical on stage.
And,
um,
I would see like that the physical
aspects of him moving around.
Was it really half?
Yeah,
half the belt and hilarious.
And any comic that doesn't believe
that isn't a real performer.
Yeah.
And when it comes for that,
when it calls for that rather
is nothing wrong with anybody.
Just Pasal little,
but it became a thing.
Do you remember when it was like a
thing amongst comedians that if you,
you know,
they like didn't respect guys who like
put forth too much after when I came to
the comedy still,
because I had some,
you know,
at that time with the cassette tapes,
I have my on tapes
Travolta and do it like I would
do to grease lightning number.
I felt like I felt like the,
the Serpico of the comedy
store because comics would go,
you know,
this is the music store and
not the comedies and this
is the comedy store and at
the music store.
And I got,
because you can't do that.
How does that sound?
You know,
you just can't do that and you
don't look like this to do that.
You're an ugly guy.
You know what I mean?
So you should be doing what you'd,
oh,
I had argument after argument with comics.
I go,
well,
you know what the club
on it thinks I am funny.
Well,
there's always,
there's a weird thing amongst comedians
when they want other comedians to be
doing,
they're kind of comedy.
It's ridiculous.
It's like a rapper going up to a guy
who plays jazz and get mad at him for
liking the fucking flute.
Yeah.
But you know,
I also feel what comics is,
you know,
not enough.
I'm where we,
I've told you that.
I agree.
Look,
You know,
I just don't feel they
back each other up enough.
That's why it's always good.
Like when you came to my show,
I was thrilled because he has another
comic that I respect coming to see me
perform.
It's almost like,
you know,
you know Sinatra going to see Sammy Davis,
so you know,
like they back each other up with it.
Yeah.
It's very important to me.
Uh,
I think,
uh,
the,
first of all,
as I've gotten older and been
doing standup longer and longer,
the more I've appreciated
the art form of it,
you know,
whether it's the style that you do
or the style that even Seinfeld,
I'm,
I'm a,
I'm a fan of any style of good.
Like,
so I love that.
I love Gaffigan Catholic
and it's fucking hilarious.
Very clean and like
anybody can listen to it,
you know,
I love that style as wow.
I just love the art form.
So for me,
comradery between other comics,
like it's huge,
huge,
huge area.
And put what I also like is,
is this,
I get a kick out of like the non comradery
of the clean comics to guys like us.
Yeah.
Like they look at us,
it's like,
oh look who walked in,
you know,
with a clean guy.
You know,
and Seinfeld always had
his little group of guys,
which I think a hysterical him,
Larry Miller,
you know,
pull rise a very clean,
to me the,
you know,
the,
the all similar in this styles on stage.
Well,
I think Seinfeld was legit.
That was legitimately him,
but there was a lot of guys that
came up that were like sort of what's
legitimately him,
but that that whole group had like a
certain stuff like intimidating Larry
Miller just kill fluence though.
What I'm saying is that there's a
lot of guys that became Seinfeld,
like there was a lot of very Seinfeld,
like observational guys that I don't know
if they would have been that way if it
wasn't for Jerry because Jerry had a
very specific style that a lot of those
clean guys imitated that style really
clearly and it's really no Seinfeld I
love.
I think he's just merely
just kit kills me.
I love him on TV.
I mean acting.
I mean I think he's one
of the funniest guys ever.
Did you ever see a stand up?
Yeah,
I've seen his standup.
I seen a long time.
I saw some old old evening
at the Improv was very,
very close to sound the
face and you know the way,
you know,
he's always shocked by things like that.
Very bright guy too.
That's why I don't like
to hang out with him.
He is,
he's really smart and you don't like it?
No,
no,
I love him.
But you know,
we've,
we used to do like La Jolla
together and everything
thing and you know,
you know,
there was a story where we
did a private party and uh,
you know,
and I,
the guy offered me like
$1,000 to do a birthday party,
you know,
in the hoyer and I,
I go over to Larry and I said,
we'll split the money you,
you opened for me at the birthday party,
you know,
and uh,
what's this big mansion?
And I think this is the guy that
invented a sex wax for a surfboard.
Surfboards.
And so we show up and I see
a bunch of five year olds,
you know,
and I'm going,
I called a guy and I'm like,
oh,
you really going to have me do my act?
And he goes,
no,
we got a clown for them.
You'll for us.
We are going inside.
So it was all the adults.
And Larry goes up and I'm laughing.
He does his act and now he's sitting,
it was like a one of those living rooms,
step down,
living room.
So he's sitting on the step
and he's watching me and
he's laughing hysterically,
you know,
and afterwards,
I,
I'm asking him,
I go,
you see my act every night
while you're laughing so hard.
He goes,
do you know what a stupid man you are?
And I go,
why?
He goes,
you were using a $20,000
veys as you an ashtray.
I go,
what did he taught?
He goes to the big vase
that was next to you.
You didn't know where
to put your cigarettes.
So you putting them in this
vase was bigger than me.
And he goes,
and I couldn't stop laughing because
everybody was looking at each other.
Every time he flicked a
cigarette and this veys,
he goes,
you're a very stupid man.
And it just,
his delivery would just make me laugh,
my balls off.
No,
I love those guys.
And I go,
you know,
Larry Miller was the guy that got me
into comic strip when I started out.
You know?
And that's where it all
started with the monologist.
Yeah.
You know,
I've always hated that,
that whole idea that there's like a good
way to do comedy and then there's an
easy way to do comedy because why is it
that when I would go to see a guy like
you or watch a guy like Joey Diaz,
why is it that I laughed so hard?
Like what are you telling me there's
something wrong because it's balls out,
but it is balls.
I know,
I understand.
But why is anybody saying that
there's something wrong with that?
Like that's,
there's a weird,
you know,
it's awesome.
It's awesome the way you brought up,
you know what I mean?
Like these are very clean cut guys.
Yeah.
You know,
and I love science.
I liked them as a person.
I liked him as a comic,
but they will put,
you know,
these are guys that
actually went to college.
You know,
I don't know how to talk to them.
the,
you know,
it's a different mindset education wise,
and I didn't understand all that,
but it's really,
it's,
it's a reservations.
It's like they're,
they're reserved and whereas
when you see someone like you
or someone like Joey Diaz,
it's saying something
completely outrageous.
They can't go with it.
They can't just relax and go with it.
They're restricted.
They're there,
they're pulled back.
Is that what they think?
Yeah,
there's something,
there's,
they just can't cut loose that you can't
be smart and enjoy good dirty joke.
Well that's ridiculous then
you're obviously not smart
enough because you should
be laughing at almost everything
you could possibly laugh at.
Well,
you know what,
let me see one of these fucking clean
motherfuck is cell 300 arena shows and
then I'll give it up for them.
It's very hard to sell an arena,
you know?
I mean,
I did it over 300 of those and nobody
is ever going to top that ever 300 you
know?
And I did it without like,
I don't even know,
arena officially 14,000 how many
thousands go anywhere from 15 to,
you know,
the biggest one I did was 21,500
and it was a 41 minutes sellout,
almost the Brendan Byrne and Jersey.
And uh,
I mean the La Forum,
I sold out in a couple of hours from
21,000 fucking people pictures doing
100,000,
you know,
at the rose bowl with the being the
middle act from Metallica and guns and
roses.
So what,
what happens between doing these
incredible arenas and then slowly sort of
backing away from comedy a little bit.
It was a slow thing though.
I did the arenas for about six years,
till around 95 and that's
when it didn't go sour.
I mean,
you know,
at that point,
the movie career was sort of nonexistent,
you know,
other than B movies because of the
backlash and my stand up and the press.
And so there were no big movies coming,
you know,
if the fort failing,
you know.
But even with the arenas,
I would do cut down arenas like 10,000
seats tonight and that went on for a
while,
you know,
then that will fight,
you d you know,
in this day and you do 5,000 seats today.
That's unreal.
That's a lot of,
you know,
I mean rock bands that,
it's a different time.
It's a recession.
It's just a different time.
So,
you know,
when I see a comic doing
200015002000 seats,
maybe 2,500 seats,
that's superstar them for a comic.
You know,
I mean,
think about it,
2000 people a night coming
to see you is unreal.
It's pretty weird.
I just,
you know,
always had this thing in my head,
because I was so bad.
Like I say,
you know,
my education was like nonexistent.
I mean,
school was just more of a place to go
and hang out and play the drums twice a
day,
you know?
And if it wasn't for the drums and music,
I probably wouldn't have graduated
high school because school just didn't
interest me.
You know?
That's the bottom line.
So,
you know,
I wasn't good in sports.
Not that I wasn't a big,
I just wasn't,
I just wasn't good at it.
And you know,
but a time I was 12 years old,
I was into all this stuff from doing
impressions to playing drums too,
you know,
that type of thing.
And when I got into comedy and I saw the
kind of guys you are talking about very
straight monologists,
you know,
I just want them to be
an actor and you know,
use the comedy stage to
develop my acting chops and,
and the dice thing happen.
So I decided,
well,
if I'm going to stay in
this game and be a comic,
I want to create the most
visually exciting comic
people have ever seen in the
world,
ever.
You know?
And honestly,
you know,
when you see the special,
and I got great respect
for you and what you do,
but you're going to respect the
special I because I respect that,
you know,
but,
but I mean,
you'll see what I mean because
I deliver exactly what,
you know,
all these fans I've had through
the years want to see from me.
And I like giving them
what they want to see.
I don't want to come up there
all cleaned up with maybe,
you know,
not a tie,
but you know,
I was sport jacket and just black pants.
I'm like,
for what?
You know what I mean?
This is how I like to dress.
Like,
you know,
I look good enough to dress in it,
you know?
So why not just deliver what they want
to see and just pound them over to
fucking heads with the filthy shit
that I could come up with because we're
living in the filthiest time with
the filthiest fucking people.
But yet the backlash is the
strongest it's ever been.
You know?
But I don't care about
the backlash anymore.
Years ago I did because I didn't get it,
you know,
because guys came before me,
everybody from,
you know,
Eddie Murphy,
Richard Pryor,
guys like some gone,
what am I doing any different than them,
you know what I mean?
And so now I'm at a point in my
life where if you don't like me,
who gives a fuck for you?
You know,
I don't give a fuck.
If you see tomorrow,
that's how I think about it.
If a writer writes,
if a journalist writes me
up like a bad write up,
I'm like,
well what do I give a fuck?
Do I notice the person,
the white care,
what they fucking feel?
They're the ones writing me up.
Well,
and it's,
it's not,
it's never fair cost for them Joe.
It's like,
would a jazz critic
review a hip hop concert?
No.
Why would they?
It doesn't make any sense.
So for someone to be,
you know,
a comedy critic,
it's like wow,
you know,
there's a lot of
different kinds of comedy.
You know,
he just because you have a specific taste,
a personal taste doesn't mean
the other competence I come from.
It's not for you.
I come from,
you know,
like I said,
like I like dealing with,
you know,
I love seeing the uncomfortability
of people in the front row.
I loved live performance
and that's one of the fun.
And if you're a clean up day,
like,
you know,
I just don't think I would have any fun.
I have fun like watching
the guy and like I said,
like Gaf again or watching
the guy and like Seinfeld,
but it's not the same kind of fun.
Yeah.
But you know,
Seinfeld's one of a kind.
Yeah.
But it's not the same kind of fun.
It's still not the same.
She kind of fun is like watching a guy
like you because Watson guy like you,
you will say the most
ridiculous shit ever.
One of the things that I was
howling is when I came back stairs,
a backstage afterwards and I
was talking to me about it.
Go then you're like,
I don't do any research
like we were talking about.
How does that,
yeah,
it's just about the fucking lady.
It was like how you were just like
breaking down the whole process.
I do no research.
Well,
I claim no responsibility.
No response.
If I was running for office,
I'd have to do a little
research for comedy.
That's what I try to explain it.
And that album,
that data left the died dead.
It's just about funny.
Right?
I don't care what it is,
just be fucking funny.
And I got my roles,
like I won't,
you know,
bring up a disaster
where people get killed.
You know what I mean?
We'll make fun of John Travolta.
You have strong rules.
Yeah,
I do have strong rules and that way,
you know,
like what happened with the hurricane,
there's no jokes for me
when it comes to that stuff,
you know,
because you know,
people are getting killed and there's
families that are morning these people.
So it's like,
where do I have the right
to make fun of that,
you know?
So I try to stay away
from that kind of stuff,
but when it comes to sex,
come on,
it's just sex,
so it's okay.
Did you ever feel like at a time that
you ever crossed the line though?
It's like,
did you ever say anything,
whether it's about,
uh,
immigrants or gay people or
anything when it comes to people,
you know,
like,
when I make fun of Asians
and call them China,
man,
you know,
it's just funny.
It's a funny word than Asian,
you know what I mean?
Chinaman Chink.
It's all funny.
You know?
It's a great word.
Well,
if it was an angry Chinese dude though
staring at you while you were talking
about I do it right to,
you know,
I talk about fat girls and sometimes I
got six in the front row and I'm gone.
All right,
so how much does the fat girl,
I talk about half the weight night because
I've had some bees sitting fucking in
front,
so I'll have to double her.
My wife says fat girls love
me because I talk about them,
but you know when I'm talking about
a chick that to picket in the bed,
I'm fucking around.
You know?
It's funny,
you know,
because no girl in the
crowd is going to go,
I'm not bigger than an eastern king.
You know what I mean?
They look at themselves like little
cause I'm not looking to hurt him.
I'm just looking to be funny,
you know?
And and let them laugh too.
Fat Girls are allowed to laugh.
They are.
But dental particularly fucking
blubber starts to jiggle and shit.
They don't pretend to like
fat girl jokes though,
in my experience.
Oh really?
Yeah,
I dunno.
Maybe it's just the way
I deliver my crowds.
They really like it.
They're literally rolling
in the fucking oil.
You know?
I've had a girl throw herself on the
floor and start rolling around that.
I'm looking like,
this is hysterical.
It happened once to speak.
You know,
I've had a heck of a fight with
an 86 year old woman really,
that I had to come into the middle of a
crowd on a New Year's eve and just where
was this big kiss?
It was in San Antonio,
Texas.
God Damn.
Yeah,
and this 86 she was like,
yeah,
I know that.
Not whatever part of America,
I don't follow the map that
much with the geographical shit,
but it's not,
but she sounded southern.
You know what I man,
Antonio,
Texas.
Yeah.
They have that Wang today and she's like,
it was like one of those skinny,
she was 86 or 80 [inaudible]
slapping [inaudible] gone.
You dirty mother fucker.
You are a dirty.
And she's as filthy as me,
you know,
that was one of my greatest heckle and,
and it's something I didn't get on.
I wasn't even filming.
Babs,
Holly Know 27 you know,
and yeah,
I've had some great heckle
fights in the days where,
where they would actually
look to throw lines at you,
you know,
rather than just being drunk.
Are you fucking suck?
Well,
especially on what do you do with that
for the store or some of the worst places
ever,
you know,
for Hecklin the first of
all because there's no crowd
control and second of all,
because Hollywood is always filled
with people that are unhappy.
They,
most people are not
achieving their dreams here.
The majority of people are struggling.
Sale.
Yeah,
the majority.
And you've got a lot of
like want to be actors,
want to be musicians,
want to.
If you're at the comedy store and go,
well what are you doing?
Well I'm an actor.
Okay,
good for you.
But that guy could wind up a superstar.
The place it's,
look,
it is possible,
but fun to Piss on it.
There's a lot of that bitterness that's
in the air and there's a lot of that in
the crowd.
It was one of the reasons why it's such
a good place to work out because that
was not an impressed audience.
They were not impressed with you
the other day by a guy in a wheelchair
and he comes there I guess once in a
while,
but he can't talk or move.
Like he has like one of those where he
just has like a thousand computers and
cell phones in front of them and they
put him right in the front and he,
wait a minute,
he has cell phones and computers,
everything but like a fax machine.
His hands work like his hand.
One Hand works to move on one hand it's
just pushing iPad buttons and stuff and
doing things.
But he talks through that.
He,
I,
he doesn't really talk,
he just goes like that.
And so while you're on stage they put
them right in the front row to the whole
show is just don't know.
But then he can,
he'll say something that that
means like non stuff like that.
And he's just fucking saying these
horrible things the whole time.
And then he's like that.
He's a track.
Right.
Wow.
He wants you to blow him.
But,
but no,
he's like he's just fucking with you.
And he just fucks with every single
comic and he sits there from like uh,
it's like seven o'clock or whatever that,
that,
that open mic show all
the way to like come out.
I don't know.
It drives everybody.
Yeah.
Yeah cause it,
that's a club like to work the new stuff.
And it always sucks when you have a guy
that you just have to handle rather than
working material.
Yeah.
Well the other problem is when someone
before you doesn't deal with the Hackler
and then you got to go up and then
it's already out of control cause they
already feel like that's a part of the
show and they like continue the bullshit.
Well and also,
let's be honest,
at the comedy store,
there's a lot of fucking people that,
that they just,
for whatever reason they're
still doing standup,
but they checked out a long time ago
and showed us sort of going through the
motions and it's not very good material.
And for whatever reason,
they don't have any talent
for whatever reason.
And you'll see them go on stage and then
these hackers started eating them and
then
you have to go up and back,
clean up,
clean up on aisle nine.
You know,
Christ
do go on.
I always make like there's
nobody on before me,
you know,
and just start from zero.
I don't care if somebody had a
fight with somebody in the crowd.
I'm not going up there to like,
like it's like you're
saying like just one comic,
you know,
like the whole,
the whole lineup is one comic,
you know,
getting into it with this one person,
I just start from zero and if somebody
says something dice mean comes out and
hopefully I handle it right there.
And then the comedy store was
the best workout for that place.
It's just,
it's the greatest,
you know,
I've gone through a lot of stuff.
You know,
I used to get to open Fetty
Murphy there all the time.
Mitzi would use me to know to go on after
him cause nobody wants to go on after
him.
Yeah.
You know and that,
you know,
those kinds of things that
like an honor at that time,
you know,
and you know that's how you
got to meet some of those guys.
Like you know,
and Murphy was always like,
and I didn't understand it at the time
when he would be like nervous to go out
there like on a Monday night
in the main room and I go,
what are you nervous
about that all he a feel,
you know,
I didn't get it because
once you have that fame,
now you have to live up to it.
And I did not,
I was just excited about
going on after the guy,
you know,
I got to follow prior at the store after
the burn incident and everybody was
coming to see him.
I mean you had Sammy Davis sitting
on the floor with his legs folded.
You had Burt Reynolds,
there was Sally fields,
you had to narrow their with Scorsese
and I will come up there like I was
playing a bowling alley and just go into
it and just make sure I kicked their
ass every time.
Mitzi putting you on after a strong
acts was a big move for everybody.
Big Move for me and one of the
guys that I had to I you a lot.
I followed you a lot in the early days.
Like in the 94 ish.
Wow.
When I first started coming there,
she would throw me on FTU I filed prior
cause you need to follow an animal and
not only that,
it's a,
it's good for you to go on after someone
strong because you realize you can't
have any fluff in your attic
and know many bullshit.
You've got to cut right
to the funny stuff.
You've got to,
you impress them right away,
get them right off the bat,
hold onto them.
You know,
it was like,
it's a good exercise in learning.
Like especially when
they love the guy before,
like you would be up fucking destroy and
then some unknown person has to go on
after you.
That's what she,
that's where Mitzi makes it.
Yes.
She picked the right guy for
that and Martin Lawrence,
I used to go and have to
go on and after him a lot.
I never followed mark.
Martin was in his prime.
I'll tell you,
Martin did not have as long a prime is
a lot of people did for whatever reason.
And he got into movies and it kind of
doesn't do as much special and I love him.
He's like one of my all time
fucking hilarious and all my God,
he destroyed the main room at the inn.
At the comedy store ones.
Yeah,
just leveled the place and I had to go
on after him because he was just funny.
Just look at him as funny,
you know what I mean?
And he knew it and he play off of it,
you know,
he's one of my favorites.
I mean I felt like a rank amateur when
I had to go on after him also because
especially if it's one of those
nights in the main room with that guy,
his audience,
and he's talking on stage.
Most people got up and left.
It was,
it was only like maybe 20% of the people
stayed and even them I was just like
this and he's out there now.
He's doing consciously doing it again.
He is.
I mean,
I don't know how big it is.
I Dunno,
you know the schedule but,
but I know he was at the
store really work and stuff.
Well that's great.
I hope he can bring it back to form.
He was when he was on top of it.
You know what he's,
he's great.
He's great in the movies.
I love him.
I love Eddie Murphy,
you know,
as far as you know,
raw comics go.
But Martin,
I always loved him the best because it
was his actions on state and he's a guy
that knew how to play the stage.
He'd be all over the place.
I mean I loved his first special,
you know.
What was your first years at the store?
What year was it?
I came out this still,
it was,
it was the beginning of 79 February
79 fucking seventies holy shit.
And you guys were living in that house
on your ass arrest till I almost bought
that place.
Couldn't have a big enough
yard for the dogs though.
I think there is no yard.
There's no yard off the mountain.
I looked at it and I was
living in that house.
That house was crazy house.
You got some fucking history to it.
Yeah.
That's a crazy house.
That's the only reason why
I was thinking about it.
I was like,
this is such a historic,
everybody,
you know,
Robin used to come up there all the time,
some of the bigger name and I
wouldn't even talk to these guys.
I would never talk to a big name
celebrity unless they would talk to me,
you know?
And uh,
cause I know what the thinking,
the minute you say hello,
what movie you're doing
and what's my part right.
You know,
I would never bother even when
Robin would come up to the house.
So was like,
just stay away,
you know,
and uh,
I mean great talent,
but I wouldn't look to
get in his face and go,
well I'm doing this.
And I used to have to follow him to it.
The store.
Well you knew intuitively that
it would be annoying as fuck.
That's what gets me when I go there.
You know,
these guys,
you know the cross the
boundary a lot of times,
you know,
and then they want,
it starts with the pictures and you know,
I'm a comic and you know,
they want to be buddy
buddy in once and I can't,
you know,
I don't work that way.
Yeah.
Some guy hit me with a fucking a sales
pitch the other day after a show.
We just cool,
I'm down from the show but I was taking
photos with this whole line of people
and this guy just starts rattling
off the sales pitch and just,
I mean it's going on for several minutes
and I'm just supposed to listen and I
just can't start out the patient
and after a while I go do it.
Stop.
I can't do that.
I don't have any time for anything and
I'm definitely not going to go into
business with you.
I don't even know you.
This is crazy.
But the sales pitch was just ready go.
Like this is opportunity.
But that's also what,
you know,
like directed energy.
It's what the new generationZ ,
that's what gets me like,
you know when you grow up and
all you're is looking down at
your phone,
you know when it finally you hit that
age where you have to start communicating
face to face with people.
They don't know how to do it.
You've got to shake someone's hand.
It's like shaking a fucking limp.
Fucking Dick.
You know?
They don't even know
how to give a firm grip.
Know what the fuck is that about?
What is that about?
No,
but I'm serious.
That says something about
somebody's character.
Well,
you know,
if you can say,
yeah,
how you doing?
You know,
and it's like,
I'm like,
what is that?
It's for a lot of people,
it's not no people skills.
I'm telling you,
they don't want to be manly.
I can't handle it.
It's not about the men.
They just don't know how to relate to
you unless the texting to you or emailing
to you.
They just don't know how
to have conversation.
You know?
There's definitely a lot of that going on.
This is,
there's a lot of people that are growing
up in a society that is more and more
encouraging people to control themselves
and to calm themselves down and to not
have as much fun and to be more conscious
of how other people are going to view
things and be more sensitive.
Personality in school,
they want to put them on Rhydlin.
Yeah,
I mean it's the crate.
They want kids sitting like mute and
they want to pretend that school is
interesting.
It's not interesting like the whole
policy of breaking a child down,
getting them to sit in position and
absorb information that they don't find
attractive.
That whole policy is conditioning someone
to just listen and be a fucking drone.
That's what it is.
It's not the best way to learn by far
by any stretch of the imagination.
A best way to learn would be some sort
of a one on one instruction where you
know you get to explain to them things
over and over again and you get to answer
all questions.
I was saying
when we went to school,
at least you could have a
personality in that classroom today.
If you're not just quiet and
sitting there like you're saying,
you know you're not a
good students.
That's Matt and sit this,
the quiet and sitting
there as the madness,
the ability to just sit there.
I remember when I was a little kid
and they would want me to sit down.
You'd be all of a sudden like you're
listening to something that's not fun at
all after you've just gotten done
running around with your friends
and I,
I wonder what even goes on now cause
to the phones and the iPads and all the
shit they bring to school now.
You know.
Does that even,
you know,
do your kids tell you what that stuff,
I'm sure they're listening to
music in class with her head.
Let's go.
It must drive.
The teacher's fucking bizarre.
It must the end.
You know what this is?
Just wait til they got those fucking
Google glasses and you know the of these
glasses that they're coming out with it.
You were and you,
you're seeing things in the glasses
like emails and you can get a website.
Yeah,
it's good.
Especially with glasses like yours.
Nice big ones.
This is a bigger screen,
but you'll see any,
see all your shit up there.
You can see all your photos.
You can be fucking you flipping through
them by using your finger in the air.
I'm not joking.
No,
but it's fun.
It's crazy.
Sitting in class like this.
You are literally,
you'll be able to do that and do that
in front of your eyes and make them move
and you'll be able to pick
ones and stretch them.
Going to deal with
that shit.
They're not,
they're going to have to have rules.
Yeah,
with that shit.
It'll be a called a like
a no touch interface.
It'll all be like finger movements.
You just be doing things with your finger.
It's going to be fucking insane.
And that's just the beginning,
you know?
Let's see.
It's going to keep going further and
further until you get something implanted
into your fucking eyeball.
They have contact lenses to now to do it.
Uh,
you know,
that's enough for me.
I don't believe in context.
They never did.
But the contact lenses that
allow you to see contacts,
not at all,
nothing.
Why?
I just don't believe in them.
But you believe in glasses.
Do you have like a lasix issue?
Could you go do not?
No,
you wouldn't do it.
I'm just nearsighted.
Oh,
okay.
You know,
so I try to weigh at like sunglasses
that people could see through.
You know,
there the,
you could see me good,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
do you,
so near side it means things
that are close to you.
You have a hard time.
Things that like kind of far away.
Oh,
so you see things close?
Fine.
Yeah.
But things are,
hmm.
I thought that was,
and when you're farsighted,
that's where you can
see things right here.
That's me,
man.
Yeah,
I'm chat.
Do you wear glasses?
No,
it's not that bad.
I mean I can like,
I can read my shit
this special.
No,
it can't be a dentist classes.
Right?
Like he can actually like
still look at his phone.
I can look at my phone
when you're talking about,
you're exaggerating.
It's not big.
I stopped doing that.
You put out,
are you going to tell her?
She knows.
You know what I'm doing right now.
I'm writing to see if I'm
any good at this part.
Right in the gang in new
you totally would be good.
That's what I was saying before and she
told me to do a podcast because I don't
like,
I'm not going to be,
that's good.
That's good.
That's even better.
That's even more fun.
But I don't want to just shred people.
You don't have to.
I'll have a podcast for three weeks.
I don't want to be on there.
When you and I talk,
we don't shred each other.
You know each other.
Yeah.
But I'm saying it wouldn't automatically
be you not liking the people years
assuming that I don't think it's necessary
because I don't get along with a lot
of,
and that's in real life on stage.
Well,
you and I have always gotten along and I
think it had a big part of it had to be
that I was a huge fan when I was a kid.
I remember I was having,
but it's like you brought up last
time about the first time we talked,
because you know I was starting to know
your history a little with the TV show
and stuff and that's why it
spoke to you about the road.
You know,
I was like,
you don't go on the road,
you have a sitcom on the Yale.
Like what are you waiting for?
You know?
And that's,
I think that's when you really
started going out there.
Yeah,
it was really good.
What's my cost to me.
But it was natural.
It was very good advice and
I didn't even think about it.
And also I was just assuming that
I would always have a sitcom role,
which is really dumb because like
why would you assume that the end he,
those things never last.
You know?
And it lasted for five fires,
but,
but once I started going on the road,
that's when my standup
really got a lot better.
That's the one thing I could tell with
you when you were on stage as you love
it.
See,
that's the key.
And you never lost that love for it.
It's the most fun thing about the special.
No,
it's fun.
It's still fun.
It's too fun.
Oh,
you're going to tour a lot now with them
trying to write a lot of new shit right
now.
So I've got to at least 40 new minutes
of new stuff and then a gang of stuff in
the notebook that I have to
sit and write it go on stage.
I do both.
I do a lot of making up on stage.
A lot of shit like I'll go on to,
you don't have an idea,
you know?
But there's a lot of it that I
actually sit in front of a computer.
Right.
I think to get the best results.
I like both.
I like actual writing,
sitting down,
writing things out and then
I like performing and living.
I just think that when
you take a lot of time,
when you sit in front of a computer,
taking a lot of time,
you're going to come up with more
possibilities than you will in the moment.
You know?
Like in the moment is great too.
But I think it's done an eave or
even an either or thing rather.
I think for Comedians,
I think it's important to both,
right?
Like to sit down and actually work on
your shit by yourself and to do it on
stage and just ad Lib and fuck around.
That's how I have the best results.
That's always tail.
Like young guys,
they say,
what should I like to write on stage?
I'm like,
keep doing that.
Definitely keep writing on stage.
But you should also write,
you should also sit down and write
because you get the most out of it.
I only do it on stage,
only on square rock.
I'll come up with stuff.
Not that I'm a genius with it,
you know,
it doesn't happen every night.
So you have you ever sit down
with like a notebook or anything?
And what I love is,
you know,
uh,
you know that I finally,
you know,
to give her a little credit,
she doesn't want to be
on the air or anything,
but she'll tail it the bit.
Like if I come up with something
and it goes a little too long,
she'll explain why it's got to be,
she really gets it,
you know,
and I'll show it in the bid up and
I'll be on stage and I'll kill with it.
I'll be like,
how the fuck does she know?
You know,
cause she,
she wants anything but the limelight,
you know what I mean?
And it's like she just gets it,
you know,
she'll go,
you don't understand.
Once you hit this point you
don't have to go farther with,
that's it.
That's the Joe and that they're,
you know,
and because of a Latin
background it's like all right,
I'll end it there.
But she's normally right.
99% of the time it'll be killer.
It's a funny thing with stand up comedy,
like you know,
you never know like where the bits going
to go when you first started and you
start adding on to it.
And my attitude like I would never listen
to anybody about what I do on stage,
especially in non comic
and she's not a comedian.
You know,
it would be like,
look,
when I'm on stage,
do me a favor,
stay out of it.
You know,
I didn't become who I am because
I was listening to my girlfriends,
you know what I mean?
But she really gets it and every time
she comes up with something and I do it,
it kills.
I know a lot of comics like
to work with the people.
They like to like a,
I know like Chris Rock,
when he would do a special,
he would work with a team of guys,
Dawson,
Nick Depalo and they would come
up with the bits and you know,
work on it together.
The Palos,
a good comic.
Yeah.
But I don't,
I don't think any comic,
that's a really great car.
And I think the polyps great.
Yeah.
But I don't think he's going to
look to write better rock than he
has for somebody else.
It's true.
It's just in your head.
You're not going to,
if you come up with
something fantastic way,
the writing,
you know what,
I'm going to put this on the side for me.
I'll give credit.
That's why I also believe
in being an original.
Like you know,
it comes from you.
Yeah.
I think that's important.
You know,
when I hear that a guy had a bunch of
writers helping with Watson of special,
it's just,
you know,
with them and see it thing when,
when he was stealing it,
you know that guy was stealing material.
But I'm talking about when
others are writing at field.
It's like how it doesn't
feel organic coming doesn't,
but I don't care.
That doesn't bother me.
I don't think that a musician should
have to sing his own songs that he wrote.
I don't think that a
comic should have to tell.
I think if one of your
friends right to joke for you,
you should be able to do it on stage and
it feels actually comes up with great
stuff for me.
It doesn't really.
Yeah.
And there's nothing wrong with dad,
but I,
but I feel like he knows me so well if
I'm doing like a bit on the heavy box,
you know what I mean?
You know,
first you know the bull monkey,
whatever the fuck they want it today.
You know,
like I'll just call him up and I'll
start coming up with stuff and he'll just
add these things and I go,
why don't you do that for you?
Right.
Cause he's such a peculiar character.
He's a very,
definitely when it comes
up with something for me,
you know,
I'll just like do it and kill with it.
It could just be,
well he did get me banned
from one TV show here.
Wheels did.
Cause I listened to him.
There's something wrong with me.
Like heels,
wheels tried to tell me that.
It was like a cool,
you know what he's doing?
He's got an entertainment company,
blue light into Taman.
He's got a catering company.
I heard his food's very good.
It is.
That's what's so nuts.
Some of it at the comedy store,
way back Cagnoli kids,
he'll love that I'm
saying this to you know,
but,
but he really,
like,
I went a couple of years ago and
I had to do another morning show,
you know,
and I was getting heavy into the
technology stuff about the phones,
this and that.
So as I'm driving there,
he's talking to me.
He goes,
all I want you to say if you bring up
technology is that you don't have a
blackberry and the only thing you want
black is laying underneath you and it's
got a big fat ass and the only thing
you want buried is your face in it that
your blackberry,
you know.
So I do it just the way
he tells me to do it.
And you could feel the ass stop and it's
eight in the morning to Los Angeles.
I'm going,
yeah,
I don't believe in the phone thing.
You know,
I don't like those blackberries.
The only thing I want black is normally
underneath me with a big fat ass and the
only thing buried,
it's my face in it and then it's just
quiet in the studio and you felt it,
you know?
And you know,
of course my publicist was told he
could never be on the show again.
Does that's even nobody the fuck did
they think they were going to get if
they're bringing it Clarius.
But I was just so into
the joke driving there,
Dan,
I didn't think it was that bad.
I'm going,
well I'm not cursing.
You know,
and they yeah,
it's not that.
No it's you,
it's Andrew dice clay at eight in the
morning when when people are shaving and
getting ready for work,
you know,
as a black woman on screen
with me right next to me,
they're looking like,
what the fuck is this?
So,
so today when I did this other,
you know,
Fox News,
I,
I was nice.
You worry about them a sabotaging
you or sending you up or you know,
like ready to,
you know,
those kinds of shows that
were always very cool with me.
So I always felt bad about the blackberry
joke cause I wasn't looking to offend
anybody.
I was just looking to be funny,
you know,
and,
and to me it was a funny Joe.
They should and we'll show me to say it,
which they should ban him.
They should understand first of all,
that you're a dirty comedian.
You've always been putting shit up.
Shocked by that.
But I'm also an adult that
shouldn't be listening to my friend,
you know,
telling me to do this joke
on the way Lou radio stuff.
The TV station and seeing
it being your fault.
I think people are too fucked.
I think it's wheels fault.
I think we could blame really
also if you would like,
but he had read the plain,
the newspeople.
I remember that time when you want CNN.
Well that guy had a comment
that was ridiculous,
but it was great.
That was also a good viral
video for you because,
uh,
people like it was clear,
you know,
that it didn't make any sense of
this kind of saying that you like,
you ran a gym for a while.
Well,
I just did a,
another CNN thing that'll layer
on a Saturday that actually,
uh,
Alan Duke was the interview.
Uh,
and Tom Green produced it.
Tom Green,
the comedian.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
He uh,
he had,
we did a two camera
shoot for this interview.
Oh,
he's great.
And I can't believe how it's him.
You know,
me,
I'm always doing the filming and he's
holding this heavy cameras and he's,
he just becomes a filmmaker at that point.
You know,
he's really great.
I'm good friends with Tom.
I love triggering.
He's phenomenal.
Phenomenal.
Got To get them back in here,
Brian.
Yeah.
Me and Tommy Gee,
that's is a good dentist.
Tough guy named Tommy g.
So you guys did another,
who was the guy that did the
original interview with you?
The one where you know,
the dumb guy,
you know,
the guy that interviewed me was
basically saying that guys like,
you know,
that was it.
You know that guy made a mistake.
He paid the price and uh,
that was it because he is a CNN
reporter that had no facts about it.
That the dot.
Here it is right here.
Yeah.
That turned this on
for a while.
For a while.
You were actually,
you were running a Jim,
tell us about that.
Hunting and Jim,
why don't you running a gym at some point?
Be a news guy.
What you get no fats are,
we
come on CNN and the,
I don't even know what he's talking about.
Go ahead.
You Ain't no point where
you're running a gym.
No,
no.
Running a gym.
Jesus fucking Christ had come on the
news for two seconds and he wants,
see every time I do an interview with
a guy wants to open his fucking man.
All right Andrew.
A little thank you.
Fuck yourself.
Listen to the snow.
Goes back to talking about art Carney
fill.
You went on the art Carney situation.
Where did that go?
That's
it.
You know any Korea he
might've had is over.
Yeah.
How could you just ask someone and
say that your research shows the own?
Did you,
there was the Internet back then.
What you want to know something?
What was crazy is and the guy knew it
that the next night I was at the beacon
theater and it was oversold.
It was gone.
Why was he trying to pretend that you,
uh,
you know,
that,
you know man away from stand
up and that you had weren't,
weren't doing it and we're running a gym,
but why was he the way I would put it?
I go his mom,
he probably didn't like me,
you know,
so he was like going to get me
fuck this little cock sucker.
Wonder whether they know he is right now.
I'd like to touch point.
Oh,
here he is.
He's not delivering newspapers.
That's where he is.
I know for sure it'd be a real
good Taj point is that guy's name.
I don't even know his name.
I know you are.
Are you friends with Taj?
I don't know him.
I don't know.
I watched the show with very good guy.
Very funny guy too.
But that would be an interesting thing.
Yeah.
We're gonna need to
find out homeboy's name.
W The internet will tell us,
hey,
on Twitter,
who's that guy was that
fucking guy and where is he?
All right.
What's he doing?
See if we can get them,
look at it.
Look how focused he is.
Maybe he would be a good guy to interview.
Uh,
and you could play that.
You have a son together.
Yeah.
That would be too intimidating for them.
Give a chance for him to apologize.
He wouldn't do it.
He'd be sad.
He'd be sad face.
I forgot how many millions
of hits that though.
I'm sure it did.
I watched it at least 20 you know,
I love it.
Yeah,
it was great because you know,
when you're doing,
especially CNN,
which is,
you know,
is aren't they the top
news show in the world?
How don't you have some facts,
right?
I mean,
you,
you have way more facts
than this guy have a head,
you know,
and you're a comedian.
Well,
he was,
what he was doing was just
sort of judging you as a joke,
you know,
he was like,
well,
I'm hearing or doing
an interview with some,
you know,
like his thing paid the price.
It wasn't that he,
he was diminishing or you,
you,
you were,
you were a headline guy,
line guy for a while.
You popped out and now you're
coming back for a while.
For a while.
You were actually,
you were running.
And Sam,
tell us about that.
That I never understood running a gym.
Everybody wants to think that just you
have to have all of your information.
You have to have all your ducks in
a row and your facts check to be on
television.
And that's just not the case.
Like you could get on one of those shows
and never dickless opinions and then
they fucking fire you.
I mean,
it's happened a million times
before this guy really paid.
I think he disappeared,
but he probably sucked anyway.
I mean that,
that was a shitty interview.
Like why would he talk to you like that?
Because he's an asshole because he
didn't do any fact checking because,
because like I said,
he,
you could tell this isn't a guy
that would be into two days also.
But even if you're not,
don't these guys talk to everybody?
Yeah,
he has a,
it's that fake.
We're talking,
you know,
that sort of fake on
television way of talking.
Oh,
when he came out and I could tell
something was up because you know,
I was trying to like,
you know,
a little pre,
not a pre interview,
but you know how you doing what's
called before you sit down and talk.
And he was like ignoring me,
you know?
And I was actually there with,
with Eleanor and happy face.
He was ignoring you because
he didn't want to talk to you.
And I could just,
I can just fit.
No,
there were no cameras on us.
But what,
he didn't want to talk to you
until the camera's on maybe.
Yeah.
Like,
like how don't you,
even when you do a talk show that
come over to you for a few minutes,
you know the host before you go on,
this guy didn't even want to talk.
And um,
I wish,
I don't know what was here to
tell the story because when,
when you're sitting there
doing the interview behind you,
you know,
it's in New York and it's just the full
floor of people with computers on the
desk.
So Eleanor said when you first cursed,
she goes,
you're talking about a couple hundred
people on this floor with computers.
Everything stopped.
And they all just looked up at the
computer and then it continued.
And then everybody like
lean forward to go,
is this really airing right now?
Like they couldn't believe it was airing
and then we just like ran out of there
and gotten a cab.
Like we were like,
we just robbed the bank.
Well,
CNN is not broadcast television,
so CNN is not held to the
same restrictions that the
FCC imposes on NBC or CBS
or ABC.
That's not a cable.
So when you're on cable you can say,
Shit,
we can say whatever you want.
It's up to whether or not your advertisers
are willing to still support you
while you do that.
So you aren't breaking any laws.
But if you had done that on like ABC
Nightline news or something like that,
then you would have broken
a law and then then shit.
If they've found you like
that you did it willingly.
Me You'd slip up.
I,
I just fucking got,
oh sorry.
You know you could have one of those
situations but if you clearly like like
this fucking asshole over here and you
know clearly like that today I think is
like that's a serious fine.
I think that's like a quarter million
dollars and I think you can to the person
saying,
yeah,
you can get in a lot of trauma.
I got to remember that.
But the way you did it on a CNN,
on heater,
our net,
I believe that's his name.
When you did it on CNN though.
That was,
it was like,
just do one on Hbo.
It's like the same thing.
Really.
This guy probably just
sits there all day and go,
everybody has seen this.
Just everybody has seen another
half a million are going to say it.
Now look,
it's silly.
Fox.
The road can pot.
It's very funny when you
have a guy like that.
Those guys,
they kill me.
Those buttoned up guys.
That's not him.
That is not the
guy.
That's what he turned into with
gained 150 pounds,
started a slumping fucking jerk off.
He's still a jerk off for doing that.
Well,
maybe he feels bad and he's not anymore.
No,
never forget.
Never Forget.
It feels bad.
Probably not.
Gretz is that that happened?
That's all.
Yeah.
Well am I see evolve.
Maybe when a mushroom trip somewhere
maybe we went down to Peru cause brain
cleaned out.
It's possible.
I don't like him.
I don't want to,
I don't want to get a fine.
No,
you don't get to find on the Internet
you that you can do whatever the fuck you
want.
That's why I love this show.
It's so relaxed to you if you're
having a good time here so far.
Yeah.
Mrs Dice Clay,
Mrs dice climb in the back
of his uncle on the air.
Yeah.
It's cool that you guys uh,
have this like happy touring thing too.
Like you guys are happy together
in Vegas having a good time.
Like you bring your family out,
you have your kids open for you,
Ellen noise,
your friend.
She's there.
Like you have like a
nice happy little group.
Yeah,
it's Nice,
you know,
to sister wives,
the whole thing.
I like how you did it in Vegas too
because I'd always wondered whether or not
somebody who even know what day it is.
Like a workout room.
No,
I love that.
But now I'm actually moving
to the hard rock in Vegas and,
well,
yeah,
but what I meant was like,
I always wondered like
if you went to Vegas,
like would you have to have the same act
over and over again or could you use,
you're the first guy that I heard of,
they like used Vegas,
like you said,
like the store just go in there,
but it's a tourist town.
So every week you've got
a different audience,
different convention.
I don't know what you don't do it more.
You were right.
I should,
I probably should.
So many comics are moving.
They're living there,
you know.
Well,
I'm doing it in February.
I'm a,
I'm at the Mandalay Bay,
the big room,
uh,
on,
February 1st,
and it's the day before the UFC.
It's basically the same.
They kind of liked that.
I've done that room toe.
It's where it,
yeah,
but I can't sell that many tickets.
So they,
they cut it in half and then
even cut in half is 802,
you know,
it's 800 seats cut.
I know the room.
I've done it a lot.
No,
it's one that,
no,
the room is like 1600 16,000 you mean?
No,
which one I'm talking
about in the Mandalay Bay,
they got a big showroom.
Oh,
no,
no.
They're doing it in the event
center where the fights,
it's where they have the fight.
Oh,
you're doing it now.
They cut off half the room to do the way
it's actually not even half the room.
It's more like a third of the room,
so
I think it's like close to 4,000 yeah.
But you know,
you get a tremendous following.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
It's,
it's,
it's a great place.
But I'm saying that
that's what I usually do.
I only do like,
what would you be happy now?
1,000 people showing up for you?
Yeah,
we've done that before.
I've done that a couple of times.
Yeah,
that'd be great.
Yeah.
We just want to make sure it's fun.
Alan,
Sharon office,
his name Alan Shernoff.
Oh,
there's an Allen.
He sits on the board as an advisor for a,
hold on.
I'll tell you right now.
It sits on the of the deadline club
is a career advisor for Brown University.
Anything put in front of a county?
Well that's a,
that's a strange gig.
I hope he's happy.
What's the name again?
Allen.
A.
L.
N share NOFX.
F is he on?
You never got me down.
Never got me down.
I'm still standing island.
Do you know Doug?
Stan hope is friends with
the real Jake Lamata.
I love Doug.
Stan hope.
Doug Stanhope lives in Bisbee,
Arizona Sodas.
Jake Lamata and Jake Lamata comes
over his house and plays poker.
That's where I was photos
of the two of them together.
But stay in hope himself as a sterile.
We did a show at the Wilton
together last Friday,
the end of the Mayan calendar show.
And uh,
it was,
uh,
Stan Hope Diaz me in a band.
It was really fun.
It's pretty crazy.
That's a good show.
So yeah,
it was fun.
Yeah,
it was the,
what's the band,
honey?
Honey,
they're friends of ours.
They'd been in the Holocaust a few times.
Really,
really talented band.
They're like almost like kind of
countryish kinda like rockish country.
Like they play a lot of Banjos and shit.
The girl has a tremendous voice,
guys,
a great songwriter,
great musician,
really cool people too.
So they opened up the show.
They did like four,
four songs.
Then Diaz went out and
like he's doing great.
Ah.
Couldn't be doing better.
Yeah.
He's killing him everywhere.
He didn't want a podcast though,
right?
Oh yeah.
Church of what's happening now.
But he's also,
I think he might even be there
now where I play at the river.
Ah,
stall.
Like the,
they're talking to him
about doing something.
I don't know whether or not he's decided
whether or not he was going to do it.
I think he was trying to make up his mind
whether or not he was going to do that
or not.
But um,
I think it's a great idea for
him because it's a quick flight,
40 minute flight lives in Burbank.
It's,
you know what,
it's the best gig right now
in the country for comic.
You,
you know,
you make it sound very appealing.
I just,
the idea of like living in Vegas,
but you don't have to live there,
you know,
you could just go,
you just want to see,
we drive it all the time.
We don't even fly.
Yeah.
We'll drive it,
you know,
and it's become so regular dry for us.
It doesn't feel like a long time.
You know,
we do it in four hours.
That's the best tip.
Like what's the best time to go?
Do you have any tips to drive
when you drive in there?
But anywhere between 12 and one I am
in the morning,
in the afternoon.
You fuck afternoon,
get it wrong twice.
If I'm home at night a lot,
you know,
we'll get home like five in the morning
and getting stuck on that drives.
I've been stuck on that drive.
I stopped.
No,
but I could go away when everybody's,
you know,
at work.
So,
um,
the,
going to the hard rock that,
um,
is it in the new wing?
You know,
there's a,
all those,
uh,
those new,
no,
no.
It's weird.
It's right near where the joint is.
You know,
it's,
it's when you first come in,
like you go to your right,
it's right in that area.
I know exactly where it is.
I said there was a band
there when I was there.
Yeah.
Well that room,
the vinyl is,
is a rock and roll room
where they put like new
rock bands.
That's perfect view.
How many seats,
you know,
well it'll seat about 400
and you do that once a month,
you know?
Yeah,
I'll do it like two
weekends out of the month,
you know,
two,
four day weekends.
So we spend like a week and a
half day and then we come home.
I gotta start doing something like that.
I'm telling you is trying to do in
January 9th and trying to find a room for
AVN.
I went to a comedy show.
There was Sam Aaa,
but I have no idea.
You could use a,
the laugh factory that,
uh,
how bays,
we'll just open the,
there's a last right,
right in the Tropicana really?
Cause it Jamie massage connected
and it's the laugh factory and uh,
how everything,
you know how everybody's all right?
No,
no,
he doesn't.
And I have friends with Bazell tone.
He's not.
Do you know who he is?
Yeah,
he's a calm.
I really don't know him actually
open for Rodney for like 20 years.
And uh,
so they just opened this club maybe.
How long ago Val?
About six months.
It's only open like six months.
Oh yeah.
I didn't get him a tech with Jamie then.
I hear it's beautiful.
I hear it's,
you know,
it's a good size room.
Yeah.
And it's doing well.
It's kicking ass and there's
a lot of comedy clubs,
but that would be one of the best.
Does Vegas have a comedy scene?
They have open mic nights or anything?
Well,
you have,
uh,
a lot of them do,
but you got a lot of clubs there now,
you know,
uh,
you got the bread Garrett Room.
You've got the laugh factory.
Um,
you got it.
There's a comedy club right at the
Riviera downstairs from the starlight
theater.
Does,
you know the,
it's the Riviera comedy club.
Um,
you have,
I know,
you know downtown,
there's a lot of clubs.
I never go downtown,
but books the river these days.
It's not Steve Shrimp anymore.
No,
I think no way he would keep
that after this problem.
No,
no,
it's,
it's just the Riviera books.
I don't know the,
the big guy in the soprano's,
what was his character
in the Sopranos name?
Bobby.
Bobby is Steve Sherpa.
We've known Steve like
before he was ever an actor.
He was the guy who ran the Riviera.
You know what?
I would get crazy with him too,
because I think he's a talented
guy and he's really likable,
you know?
And when he was doing the sopranos,
like one in the last,
I'm like,
where's the new show you're going to do?
Because even though he played a gangster,
they still this lovable guy
and I'm going to buy it.
You kind of have an ABC Sitcom after this.
You're the father of three.
It's that simple.
Right.
You know,
and,
and I'm still waiting for
it because I loved that guy.
It's a lot of,
it's hard for a lot of those
guys to transition from my show.
That's not memorable,
but not all of them.
See a lot of them were real
tough guys like just from,
from real life guys
that have been in jail,
you know,
some of them were,
were relaxed is but,
but [inaudible] even though
he was with the gangsters,
he still has that likability,
you know,
that he could have
transitioned very easily.
She tried to find out,
I'm like,
dude,
you know,
he might still,
they're wearing the sopranos again.
Are they really?
You should try to find
out if he could do it.
If the Riviera.
Yeah.
The Riviera comedy club.
That's a good spot.
Pick a room you want.
I want like a hundred,
like
a smaller room.
Hundred 50.
I have you ever comedy club?
Yeah.
That's easy.
I could probably help you with that.
What does the Riviera hold?
It was a whole 150 maybe.
Well,
the comedy club,
Kali holds about 300 does it?
Okay.
And then the place
upstairs where you were at,
Dad holds like five 75.
So what,
like what is that?
The place where that uh,
Mark Moreno used to have a,
Frank Marino used to
have his drag queen show.
Thanks.
So,
yeah,
there's like a couple theater.
It's the only theater I saw in the river.
There's also a thousand
seat theater just like that.
And by the way,
you got to use up the word
drag queen while you can,
before they decide to take all of that.
It's too intense.
You're not supposed to use twink anymore.
Do you know that even gay guys get
in trouble for using the word twink?
I never heard it until the
second tank in the gay community.
A twink is like a small hairless
sort of boyish looking gay boy.
Do you have any idea why did
you have to say that to me?
And then the Andy Cohen and people in,
in the audiences,
you know,
what are you a twink?
Yeah,
exactly.
That's the new thing.
And the big guys.
A bears.
Yeah,
they just wanted to be called tings.
But Andy Cohen,
the guy who runs bravo got in trouble.
Uh,
he forced to apologize for,
uh,
calling someone twinks.
He had to like,
he's,
and he's gay.
He's a gay guy and I love this show.
I love that a gay guy had to
apologize for using the word twink.
I mean,
that is God damn cold and I love that guy.
He's trainees that they don't want
to be called trannies anymore.
I used to call them goals.
Well,
yeah,
that was my joke.
I go,
you meet the girly a dreams,
right?
Like I would start off,
I go,
you know,
first you got these bisexuals.
You know,
what does that mean?
You either suck dick
or you don't Suck Dick.
Right?
What do you get up in the morning?
I got to remember this shit.
You know,
flip a coin heads.
I want hip height,
tails balls across the nose,
and then I go and now you've
got these other things.
He's a trans testicles.
You meet the girl,
he had dreams.
You want to know your dining.
You put your hand up a script,
you're holding a fucking tree trunk.
You know,
this is what the guy said.
Okay,
this is how crazy people are today.
Andy Cohen,
who's the guys,
he's,
I guess he's the head of Bravo,
I guess he's always on those shows.
He's always like acting as a,
uh,
you know,
we watch the show here.
Well he's,
this is what he wrote on Twitter.
No joke.
I just raw walked right
into one direction.
Green Room,
I guess one direction as a band.
The blonde dude was shirtless.
He says,
and then his tweet Hashtag holy
twink so he's calling the blonde.
He said the blonde dude was a twink.
He's like,
obviously he's saying he's like a
hot little piece of ass and he had to
apologize for that
misused word earlier.
I just meant they're cute.
He tried to write that
to cover up his truck.
That's what we've been talking even,
you know,
cause we were talking
about it with comedy,
but think about that.
That's so ridiculous to say.
You got to,
you know,
have a,
an apology ready,
quit Twinkies.
It could you call a press conference,
get behind a fucking podium and go,
I'm sorry.
I called the little hot boy.
A twink.
Twink is a contentious word and is
sometimes seen as a derogatory definition
referring to a certain type of homosexual.
Thus Andy experienced crazy Twitter
backlash concerning his comment.
What a group of contacts we have,
which is the s just a
bunch of silly cunts.
Just silly dumb people.
Yeah.
Now how come people don't
get mad at that word anymore?
I Dunno.
I'm going to use that word to the wheels.
Fall off.
I will never give up.
Kind of hold onto Khan.
You will prime my dead.
Hands off the word con.
I apologize too.
Like who was like a bangle?
Twinks yeah,
it's,
Bob says you have to
apologize to the fans,
I guess of the band.
That's what he had to
apologize for using that word.
But the people were upset that the
word twink was a derogatory term,
but it's being used by a gay guy.
It's like me constantly.
Again,
it's silly.
It's stupid,
but just like check out those
twinkle twinkles I mean there's,
there's so the craziest culture,
even in the harshest conditions.
Most of my family's Italian.
If I called someone a crazy
Guinea and you got mad at me,
you can go fuck yourself.
That's not racist.
It's me.
I will tell you,
I'm a mostly,
I'm mostly Guinea,
you know,
and that's a source of all sorts
of problems with me biologically.
And they did say that.
You can't say that it's,
it's fucking stupid.
This guy is a gay guy and
he's calling someone a twink.
If there's wrong with that,
there's no hope for world.
That's what I'm saying.
People talk,
you know what?
Everybody like it,
you know,
we can't have that.
It's just fucking stupid already.
You know,
you say a little thing,
a cute little thing,
you know,
he was looking at the guy,
it got probably look,
I mean who dresses better than Andy?
Not only that,
it's like he's dressed perfectly every
me and my wife watched the show cause we
watch all those crazy,
you know,
housewives,
you know the Miami,
you see them?
Yeah,
they fight.
They're the only ones worth watching.
They fight,
you know,
let's Cuba bitches this,
they're tropical.
They'll throw low that
you could understand.
You know what I mean?
Like when we go to Florida,
my wife will catch me just watching the
Tele Mundo and all the dressing rooms,
you know,
and now you can at least understand
what the fuck they're saying.
It's a Ma amazing that just following
idiots around with a camera has become
awesome entertainment.
But at sometimes that could take it.
Sometimes I can't.
Yeah,
this is me,
you know,
because it's,
you know all those shows.
It's about the fight now.
You know it's always about the fighting.
You know what I watch man,
I don't want to see these chicks banging.
All are these days is Alaska shows.
I've been on this crazy Alaska kick for
the last couple of months cause it's
like four or five different shows about
people trying to survive in Alaska.
It's fascinating shit man.
Watching people out there just trying to
catch as many salmon as they can freeze
because they have to realize that it's
going to be winter for eight months.
That's all I've been watching.
So I watched that and then I watch
like the real housewives shows and they
looked so stupid because
their issues are so small.
Like in the Alaska shows,
they're like,
I got to go show you.
You can't compare,
you know?
Yeah.
You know,
real life shit to a,
you know,
well you called what I did and you
know Anneka and they stand for that.
And then the one with the boyfriend that
just as fucking everything behind her
back split.
We love each other.
Shut up and fuck somebody else already.
Let's start a new storyline here.
What am I going to see?
13 episodes of you fighting with
the guy that owns nightclubs,
about other chicks.
Didn't you know what you
were getting involved in?
Did you use your fucking head
for a split second already?
Yeah.
He's silly bitch.
You know,
that's,
that's what goes on with these girls.
It's like,
just stop it if he's not feel
bang somebody else already.
Well it's just interesting that that
would even be entertaining to people.
It really is because so much pleasure.
It's almost like saying to people,
get out of their cars
and start an argument.
You're going to watch it.
But when I watched the difference
between no shows and these Alaska shows,
these subsistence living shows,
but I do because it's humans.
I'm just watching humans in Alaska live
their life and it's like I'm watching
live their life they live in and looking
to survive to the problem is what I
think is that all their,
their,
their natural needs have been taken
care of as far as like gathering food,
having a place of shelter,
being protected from the elements.
You don't have to worry about that.
That's interesting to watch because they
don't have to worry about that shit.
Then they constantly on this bitch
says something to me and I'm going to
conduct,
they're always fucking drunk.
Every fucking show,
every radio.
I don't want to get
angry over reality shows,
but every one of them,
you know,
well let's meet for breakfast
and they're opening up dumb.
Right.
You know,
well,
why are we drinking at breakfast?
Because you don't have to go
collect Caribou and all of that.
That's right.
Yeah.
You're not cutting a hole in the fucking
night if you have to go out there and
go shoot a bear.
Otherwise you have no
meat in your freezer.
That's a completely different situation.
This thing.
Yeah,
it's what it is.
You know,
I can't feel bad,
you know,
for a girl that's living in
an 18,000 square foot home,
you know,
drinking liquor for breakfast,
but I could feel bad for the,
you know,
the Little Alaska and guy that my fault,
where the ice.
I feel like if I had to choose between
living with those cons in Miami or live
in,
in Alaska,
I would live in Alaska and I'd
have to go with the Miami thing.
I don't think it would be able,
if I had to live with them.
If you had to live in a house with
those people or live in Alaska,
it's still a chip.
There's,
they're so dumb.
There's so much dumbness.
There's so much where you would just like,
I'm going to have to hypnotize you people
and start from scratch because there's
only one way.
We're gonna have to raise your mind
and I'm going to have to program,
you know,
I'm going to get up.
You have a lot of checks to see.
I'll tell you a show you would
like cause it reminds me of you,
the way they explain everything happening.
Uh,
what is it?
I shouldn't have been around it,
but I was what?
What's the name
should be
the Nitel or your next album.
And she should been around them.
But I always forget the exact,
she knows what going to be alive.
I shouldn't be alive.
Oh
yeah.
Like you know what I mean?
I shouldn't have been around live,
but it was,
they decide what a beautiful day I'm
going to climb the biggest mountain in the
world.
Yeah.
Well thinking,
you know,
this is going to go off without a
hitch with that guy when it through his
fucking arm.
The guy who got stuck under that
rock and they made a movie about him.
No,
but have you watched the
show I'm talking about?
Yes.
Yeah,
I've seen it.
Yeah.
And they explain things like,
you know,
I always go back to salt,
mineral is a mineral.
That lady that's still
probably sitting there shaking.
You know,
I get so mad over the woman's a monster.
She was a monster all night.
She's a monster in the
audience who's a monster.
And she was like a middle aged lady,
right?
No,
no.
She's like late thirties overweight.
Angry.
Nope.
And you weren't even looking at her and
she was like talking to somebody else
about salt and what you call it again.
Oh no,
she was telling everybody how good for Ya.
Just sitting minding his own business
and all of a sudden the rage,
you know,
it was like a show off the stage.
It goes,
what the fuck are you talking about?
What do you know about anything?
Like he knew her.
Like she knows nothing about anything.
He goes,
hey,
tough fucking mineral.
You tell this story
every time you do this.
I love cause you didn't see your face.
That was the beauty of that.
And I explained to you that that
kind of had been a problem all night.
But I always forget that part.
Yeah,
that part's not as interesting.
But when you know,
when she was telling people about salt,
but you shouldn't have
any salt in your diet.
And I was like,
what?
It says the central mineral stupid.
Like,
what are you talking about?
Tow.
It started and then you've got to change.
Then it was Rogan mean that
she wasn't there for that.
I wasn't there.
That was when it got,
you know my other thing,
I know I bring that up all the time,
but I like the way you break
things down is what I'm saying.
That's what I was really like on the show.
Like uh,
I shouldn't have been around it,
but it was like they break it down
like everything that's happening to the
person and I know you really
understand those things.
That shows a bad show.
I'll tell you a thing I like to do
on different shows with the same guy,
like if it's the same host
of a radio show or something,
I love to congratulate them
on their wife's pregnancy.
Knowing there is none,
you know?
And if the second time
the guy would be like,
dice you said this last time,
my wife isn't pregnant.
And I go,
no,
what,
what?
She had the baby and he's called,
she was never pregnant.
We don't even want kids and
they get angry about it.
And I'll just stay on
it every time I come on.
But that's purposely,
well you would have these,
I love to effect people.
These little gags that you
would run at the store.
We'd have people like
acting out certain things.
You were videotaping it with cameras so
you'd like get off stage and there was
like a play going on
in the fucking hallway.
Like what?
What is happening?
You got to see those tapes.
I'm telling you.
What do you do with all those tapes?
Nothing.
This is what I think the pilot has to be.
I just love filming it.
I this is what the,
I think [inaudible] your podcast.
Tom Green always calls me up.
He goes,
let's film something.
And I'm like,
for what?
All I do is film.
Cause he likes doing that shit too.
But he'll actually air somewhere.
He'll put it somewhere.
How awesome would this be if you had,
you just had a humongous box of tapes
behind you all random and each podcast at
the beginning he just grabbed one,
put it in.
He kind of gave like a
commentary while it's going on.
Like,
oh,
this is from,
you know,
the comedy store obviously.
Let's see what's going on here.
What I was doing it,
no,
that's actually funny.
But that was since to those tapes,
you know,
even though it seems like when he goes,
Joe,
it asks me,
he goes,
what are you doing with the camera?
And I'm like,
I'm filming the show.
But that was no show,
but yet I was making it a
show and I really just love,
so when I'd come to the comedy store,
you know,
I'd still kicking weight and the show
is going on in the original room.
I used the store as my set,
you know,
and like the newer comics at the time,
like,
uh,
like Steve Run is easy.
You know,
Ori,
uh,
Bobby Lee,
these were like the,
the new generation of comics coming.
So I would,
I would film all these guys and they
couldn't wait for me to get there because
they never knew what they had to do.
And I would tell them exactly
what I need them to say,
you know?
And I would say,
all right,
you wait four seconds and you say it
exactly like they didn't even have a
choices.
How to say it as an actor,
why didn't you do something with it all?
Who am I going to do?
But you spent so much time,
we were looking forward to it.
You have no idea how.
I was like,
wow,
one day I die,
it's going to release it.
And you're like,
oh okay.
Well my son Max says,
you know,
we got to,
these are the lost tapes.
We got to call them and start
putting things on like youtube,
have them edit it into little cause
said we'll always scenarios going on.
How many hours of footage do you have?
Oh thousands.
Thousands.
You know,
just madness.
I have this,
uh,
this,
cause I did film a lot of
stuff career wise that um,
there's this young filmmakers
names John Myers and he's,
he's putting together,
he's lugging all my footage now to make a,
you know,
documentary movie.
That's what it was.
But I filmed,
you know,
all the way back.
Like first it was all the
big shows being on the road,
all of it.
I'd get my home life if that's
how I started with practicing.
Just filming myself without a crew.
And the special comes
out this Monday night,
New Year's Eve as Monday night,
right?
New Year's Eve.
This Monday night show time.
What time is it?
10:00 PM 10:00 PM and uh,
and so it's over at 11
it's a one hour show.
So set your dvrs if you're
not going to be home,
if you're out partying
second dvrs and check it out.
That show that I saw in
Vegas was fucking awesome.
And the best comedy
shows I've seen in a long time.
Last 10 years.
You read bed,
we fucking how old?
It was really fun.
It was,
it was just a fun night
with you guys hanging out.
It was,
we had a great time.
It was old school dice and it was,
you know,
Anthony Kumi and Jim Norton and Sam.
It was,
we had a great crew.
Bobby Kelly was there too.
Yeah.
I love that you made
me like love that guy.
I know Bobby Kelly.
I didn't know him up to that point.
He's the best.
Yeah.
Just a nice guy.
You know what I mean?
Very,
very.
And of course I had a fuck with him at
the beginning and what he to that can't
get a picture for what?
Yeah.
You know,
we don't know each other.
like why would you want a picture of us
like in a book and then I took like 20
of them with them.
Yeah.
He loves you that that
show is fucking phenomenal.
And that's going to be the basement,
the same set as it's more
intense than what you saw.
I mean the same material,
a lot of the same fucking great,
great,
great stuff.
And it's like I said,
it's old school dies.
It's really like going
back to some of your,
your earlier work,
keeping the voice it would say and just,
you know,
pounding on people aggressive.
Well,
yeah,
I got pretty aggressive with some guy in
the front row that wanted to talk when
I'm doing,
you know,
film,
and I had to threaten him,
but I left it in,
you know,
because I know people watching.
You're going to look and go,
yeah,
he's threatening to choke this guy.
Yeah.
You know,
it was great stuff.
It's great material.
And if it's even better than that,
then the show that I saw in Vegas,
because I still had months
after you were there,
so other bits came.
I appreciate that,
man.
I really appreciate guys
who are disciplined,
who really work at stuff and work
at putting together a real sad,
and I know you do and I love the fact
that you really ended up doing comedy
again.
I love the fact that when
I talk to you about it,
you're all excited about it.
You could see it when you prefer.
I get them pumped up when I'm coming here.
It's very fun.
Oh,
we get pumped up to have
you follow dice on Twitter.
It's the real dice clay,
one word,
the real dice clay on Twitter.
Everyone else is a phony.
How many funny guys you got on Twitter?
A lot of them.
That's why even a on my,
what's
the new site again?
What's it called?
Yeah,
yeah.
Andrew dice clay official
page,
you know,
is there another Andrew dice,
clay.com what?
Yeah,
there's phoneys out there.
That's what I'm saying.
So we have the,
that's why it's Andrew dice clay official,
but Andrew dice clay.com.
Do you own that?
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
but official.
So there you go.
Pam.
Andrew dice clay official
and it's the real and drew.
Now the real dice clay though.
Real dice clay Twitter.
And if you can't find it,
just go to my Twitter.
I just retweeted it or I
just tweeted it out there.
Um,
so what's La Rocs Twitter,
do you know?
Hello
La Rocs the band.
So go follow those two
you fucks and see if,
thank you very much brother Dan.
Good luck on New Year's Eve.
It's going to be awesome.
We'll have a happy new year.
I kick ass in 2018 and I'm so
excited to see you out there.
Just fucking,
I'm laying them down again.
That's beautiful.
All right.
Thank you very
much everybody.
Thanks for tuning in and thanks
to on it for sponsoring the show.
Go to o n n I t use a code name,
Rogan and save yourself 10% off.
Thanks to death squad.
Go to [inaudible] dot TV to find future
comedy dates is linked to pretty much
all of us.
Um,
and then it's insurance in Friday's
Friday's show at the ice house yet.
Oh at 10 o'clock.
Tickets are on sale@icehousecomedy.com.
You're allowed to say
Doug Benson his name yet?
Yeah,
no.
All right.
So he uh,
Nick Rutherford,
Kevin Christie,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
and we've got a couple of surprises that
couple surprises that
may not be what do you,
what are you headline that every Friday?
No,
no,
this is Friday.
I'm in Vegas.
I'm doing the UFC in Vegas.
But you're always bringing that up.
Do you normally do that?
Yeah,
we do the ice house all the time.
When I'm in town,
I'll just come there was set.
We do a pro podcast Friday.
I won't be there though.
No,
but not even a,
but he does.
You go on stage,
right?
Yeah.
I won't be there this week.
No,
not this what I'm saying.
I always see you bring it up.
Yeah,
we do it a lot of times on weekdays.
A lot of like a lot of like a
Wednesday nights and stuff like that.
But I,
I'll have some other weekends coming up.
Uh,
I think at the Ice House as well because
I got a a few weeks off in January and
it's a weekend there.
I never ever want to let me know.
Okay.
It's a beautiful,
beautiful,
it's like the common store
without all the cantinas.
Like everyone's nice there and he,
the owner's suite and everybody's like,
really happy to have you there.
And the crowds are phenomenal.
They're like,
Pasadena is like,
they're not like city people.
They're like a little bit more relaxed
and it's a loose fucking crowd.
They're fun.
One of my favorite places ever.
Yeah.
You love the shit out of that place.
All right.
You fuckers,
we'll see you next week with a
guest to be named at a future date.
But we've got a lot of fun people.
We're going to have a good time.
Thank you everybody for
tuning into the podcast.
Thanks for all the positive
feedback about my comedy special.
I appreciate the fuck out.
He paying five bucks for it.
Uh,
it's a beautiful thing to get so much
support and so much love and we sent it
right back at Ya.
All right,
so go fuck yourself and
we'll see you next week.